(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, what's a good word?
I know it's been an extended minute.
Roll-On went dark for a bit of a prolonged hiatus,
but worry not.
And Adam and I did not break up, we are in good stead.
The respite due solely to things like travel,
alternative programming, other matters,
scheduling and miscellaneous, but fear not,
we are back and all that pent up excitement and anticipation
will soon burst forth.
So commence, we shall.
My name is Rich Roll, once again,
I encourage you to applaud the illusion of freewill
that directed you towards your predetermined destiny
to absorb this content today.
I hope this transmission of ones and zeros find you loved
in the analog world and in a grateful, open,
and capacious mindset to receive
because, because I am joined once again
by my favorite spice lord, Viceroy of beaches,
Malibu vicar of words,
noble humble chaplain of wetlands and wit dry,
the good sir, Adam Skolnick.
He's not a man, he's a planet.
For those new, Roll-On is our sometimes emphasis
on sometimes biweekly shuffle step a scance
from my traditional fare of evergreen conversations
to get a bit silly.
I think it's fair to say,
hone in on matters of contemporaneous import and today,
in the interest of always tweaking the format,
we tweak the format so much.
I'm not sure we actually have a format, Adam, do we?
At this point, everything's out the window, nonetheless,
we again do just that.
So, after our half cocked banter
that you've come to know and love,
for the second part of the show,
we're gonna share my conversation with ultra runner friend
and friend of the pod, Robbie Ballenger,
that was recorded on October 9th at the explorers club.
It was part of a live event hosted by my partners
and friends at Ten Thousand to celebrate the launch
of my kit collaboration with them, the Free Association Run
or Far collection of men's running gear,
get your hands on that stuff by the way,
that also involved a group run in Central Park.
But while we have that to look forward to, right now,
I have Adam right here.
So, what's say you good, sir?
What's going on?
I figured we gotta get this going.
The interloper is here.
It's gotta happen.
I think people might not realize that Brogan and Adam
haven't actually met-
No.
Before.
I think, if you're, can we do it?
No, we'll save it to the-
Yeah.
(upbeat music)
This is the best day of my life.
(indistinct chattering)
(upbeat music)
First of all, thanks for not inviting me again this time.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah.
You just can't stay away.
What happened?
Did you hijack a plane to get here?
I flew nonstop from Minneapolis to Los Angeles.
Mmh.
And I got a camper van,
called the White Tiger from a caveman.
All right.
And I drove it here to the Hills.
And now I'm sitting with these two brilliant men
and I feel like-
We showed up today, you're just parked out front in a van
with a surf board and a skateboard waiting for us to arrive.
And quite frankly, you're are too big to live in a van.
Yeah.
(Rich laughing)
First of all, that's a little bit messed up,
but that's fine.
What else did you expect though?
When you didn't invite me to this show?
I don't know.
It looked kind of like I was having a garage sale.
I mean, I threw you a bone.
I let you do a couple ads, we played up the whole,
Brogan-Adam, you know, kind of rivalry here-
We built the biggie Tupac thing.
Yeah.
And the thing is, by giving me the ads though,
is like now I smell blood.
In terms of like, now I'm just-
That was intended to placate you, so you could go-
Oh, to go away?
So you'd go away happily.
You talk about macro bars and then be done.
And Adam and I could get back to business.
I just felt like-
It was a plug at placation move.
What started as a joke of, I'm gonna get that guy's job.
Right.
We got a little bit of some rumblings
from some Adam and Rich fans,
right?
Right.
Which is awesome.
They came to your rescue.
I don't think I was serious at the beginning,
but then it started to become a thing.
Yeah.
And then we did the ads-
Where you taking out that billboard, was weird.
That was weird.
It was actually a lot cheaper than you think.
(Adam chuckling)
And, it's like a three for one deal.
I mean, yes, so you got Sunset Strip, Times Square,
and then what's the place?
Where would you do it in Minneapolis?
Downtown Minneapolis, right next to the Grain Exchange.
(Rich laughing)
It's actually outside the window that I work at,
so it's like, when I'm feeling down,
I look out there I'm like,
I am gonna kill that guy, Skolnick.
(Rich laughing)
And it's just, you know, it's a casual 50 foot.
I mean, it was, let's just say it was a bit much.
It was, but-
It's proving the adage of give an inch, take a mile,
because here's the thing-
But we're all learning.
Adam's job is secure.
So I don't know what your agenda is.
All right. So go back to the timeline.
I say in the public setting,
I'm gonna take that guy's job.
I said, "I'm gonna bring that guy down."
You laughed, very encouraging.
There's some rumblings.
Right?
And then I started-
It wasn't meant to be encouraging,
it was meant to be dismissive.
Yeah, go away.
Dismissive laughter?
Do the macro bar ad and go home.
I'll play it up for yucks on the podcast.
But in truth, there's no threat.
And then I started doing my homework, on this Roll-On,
this love, this romance-
You actually listened.
I started listening to the show and managed good-
You wanted to replace me without listening.
I mean, you're not the only one.
You're not the only one.
(all laughing)
We've gotten those messages too-
I'm gonna take that guy's job.
What does he do?
(Brogan laughing)
Is he on the show?
So then I started listening to the ritual podcast.
Yeah.
The Roll-On is incredible.
I started doing the homework, "Lonely Planet" stuff,
"Deep Sea Diving" stuff, "The Blue Hole,"
Right.
"One Breath," is that the book?
Yeah, yeah.
"Deep Blue."
I did "One Breath" on audio book.
By the way, if you read, if you do an audio book,
can you say you read the book?
I think so.
In 2021, you can get away with it.
So I read your book, and I think I started with this thing
of like, I'm gonna study this guy, and then bring him down.
I'm gonna like occupy his flesh and flex and he's gone.
And then, we'll surgically trade faces.
Oh.
Right?
That'd be a great move.
Like what is it?
Nicholas cage?
Yeah.
Anyway, and then the more I learned about you,
I just like you, I fell in love with the guy.
Aww, okay.
So now I'm here to make the peace.
Well I think we should attempt to do that.
Can I say something really quick?
It is awesome to be hip deep in the metaverse with you guys.
Come on.
It's the first time I've been in the meadow with you guys.
This is an analog version of the metaverse.
Oh, it is?
Right now.
As far as we can tell.
Yeah.
Did you guys catch Zuckerberg's-
The super advanced version of the metaverse.
It's the advanced one.
He's going full Oculus.
Did you catch Zuckerberg's presentation?
'Cause I love the way he's so natural and authentic.
Right.
It's just like, I can watch him all day.
(all laughing)
Yeah.
Zuckerberg.
I spoke at an event
at Zuckerberg thing and he told his assistants-
This thing I think called Facebook.
Facebook, a global event, I spoke there.
It was like the coolest thing.
I was so scared, but I got off the stage
and I gave him the mic.
And when I got off stage, I was like,
"Oh, that was Zuckerberg."
I was so pumped to be done,
that I didn't even really think in the moment.
It's so crazy, right?
He's this world famous, guy who cares.
But his assistant said,
"Stick around, he wants to talk to you after the thing."
Oh!
Mmh.
And I was like-
It was my story.
It was about community.
He wanted to talk about community.
And I was like-
Did he wanna talk about like foiling?
Right, or like how everyone in the surf community
hates him.
(Rich laughing)
Anyway-
Not everybody.
Talk it, who?
Well, we'll get there.
Okay, fine.
Anyway. And then I stuck around for his presentation.
It was very natural, very organic like you said.
The charismatic brought me in.
(Adam laughing)
He really brings you in with those eyes.
I was leaning in, and then he blew me off
and then I waited through the whole thing-
Did you get his cell number?
(Adam laughing)
His assistant goes, "He has to catch his flight,"
and I go, "Doesn't have a jet?"
And hey go, "Yeah."
I was like, okay.
Don't they leave when he says?
He can just say he wants to undo the idea.
I really love to talk to that guy anyway.
Yeah.
I gotta be back.
I decided I don't.
Yeah.
One hour later I've decided I don't anymore.
(all laughing)
It wore off half-life of the broken experience.
I give a good one hour-
You're all in.
I give a good few minutes-
And then you're like, yeah, I've had enough.
Yeah, I can't wait to hear the fans comments.
The ritual comments.
Yeah, we're good on this guy.
Less is more.
Yeah. Yeah.
So anyway-
Adam has a rabid fan base that are very protective of him.
So, you're rolling the dice and taking a risk,
even showing up.
And now my showmanship in the front and all my, you know,
my banter now it's kind of like,
it's kind of ricocheted back because right now,
I'm a part of the fan club.
I'm a fan club of this guy, but I mean-
Of course.
You're awesome.
Thanks.
I think you're awesome.
I'm a fan of yours.
Well, and for those things-
I think your laugh out loud funny.
How about that?
I think we laugh when we talk on the phone,
that's a thing.
Should we just go right into the therapy now?
Let's do it.
I think we should do that, right?
This is off to a good start, but I will moderate.
Okay. Got it.
The commencement of this relationship.
He knows therapy.
We have to have to traverse a few rocky shoals
along the way.
That's true.
Given that Adam has does have a rabid fan base
and that people are very protective of him,
I'm here to say that Adam's job is very secure.
Okay.
I'm unclear on how I feel about you being here today,
but I'm pro you guys getting in a room together
and hash it out.
This is a step.
So, should we start with resentments and fears?
Yes, let's do that.
Do an inventory-
Okay.
yeah.
Adam?
I go first.
Yep.
I resent that, I was managed to trace back
'cause as many people who have defended me,
there have been stone throwers who have come at me
and blamed me for-
Starting.
For being a part of this show
and turning it into something it wasn't.
And I've learned, that you were behind it all.
(all laughing)
This is a bot, like a bot farm?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I didn't realize-
That broken, deployed-
Yeah, yeah, from his coworking space.
Totally, totally.
My coworkers is a bot farm.
Brain exchange.
Yeah, totally, and you've been there.
You being the one guy sitting in the middle of this giant-
Pulling levers-
Riding a skateboard around-
Controlling a farm of Russian-
Right, prove he doesn't know Vlad Putin.
I can't.
Right.
So, that's tough.
So that's a resentment,
I'm willing to, so that's it.
And my biggest fear is,
you're younger, better looking and more popular than me.
Okay, good.
That feels good.
Not much younger.
Taller, I'll take taller.
And taller.
I'll take taller.
And better on all board sports.
Got it.
And basically all sports.
Okay. Got it.
Yeah.
Got it.
And to be fair,
there's a little audacity with the kind of tenor
with which you like a bull in a China shop,
like bullied your way into this whole situation.
Absolutely. It's very unfair.
But it's very like me.
There was a moment where I thought,
I could be tossed to sander.
(all laughing)
No, no!
There was a moment where I thought like, well,
he does have a, you know, a certain charisma about him.
Should we create a little context in case somebody
is brand new to this whole thing
and doesn't know what we're talking about?
Yes, I think that would be smart.
Do you wanna try to recap it?
Yeah. The late winter, early spring,
you and the crew came to Minneapolis.
Mm-mmh.
You were sitting down with civic leaders
and I think the Roll-On wasn't new,
but it was kind of like catching a stride.
But that trip was at your invitation.
Right. So, because I am connected to Jacob Frey,
recently reelected mayor of Minneapolis.
Oh, look at that.
There you go.
(indistinct chattering)
'Cause you dropped Zuckerberg-
Zuckerberg and Jacob Frey.
So it's subtle.
It was subtle-
(indistinct chattering)
Zuckerberg and I kind of brought him in.
Yeah. So anyway, keep track.
So that's two and then,
but I think I hit you up about the Minneapolis experience
and then, and you thought it was a pretty good idea.
You press go pretty quickly got your whole team in.
Yeah.
Which is kind of new to mobilize for y'all.
And then I had been, with all that was going on in 2020,
I was doing a little bit of time away from podcasts
in general, but right around when you and I reconnected,
and I would say you and I exchanged short films like,
maybe once a month during that era.
Mm-hmm.
It's more now.
As I come to Minneapolis, do some stuff-
When you count the short films,
do you just count the total number
or do you count the number you get back?
It's a harvest, right?
(all laughing)
Like if you say, we've exchanged 50 short films,
but 40 were yours?
(all laughing)
Totally, 100%.
Yeah.
I think a short film experience is a trade, one-on-one.
Yeah, I agree.
So 50 would be 100 films.
Based on the frequency and volume of short films
that I know I'm on the receiving end of them
and I know Adam is.
Right.
My estimation is that you leave your house in the morning,
(all laughing)
you ride your bike to the Grain Exchange,
gotta working space.
Yep.
Wherein you spend the next six to eight hours
sending people short films and basically videoing yourself,
skateboarding around, and then you go home.
That is not completely right.
But your close.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah. I mean the short film, you know, and that dates back
to other stuff of like that's my exchange.
Again, we're talking to people who are just doing it,
short films, it's just texting a video
showing your scene, whatever.
And that was a kind of a favorite way-
You're very good at it, by the way.
Thank you. And you've gotten strong too.
Thank you.
This Adam Skolnick short film is,
and not that I don't wanna box you in with the style.
But recent genre coming from your phone is,
almost always there's music.
Yeah.
Usually a child named Zuma in your arms are within reach.
There's slow dancing, straight facing into the camera,
and then-
Duck face.
Almost, and I wanna say regularly the last half dozen
finish with a cameo of a pot of oatmeal on the stove top,
which I think, I mean, I'm writing letters
and using a typewriter, but like the stove top oatmeal.
I haven't seen in awhile.
I am a six star stove top oatmeal chef.
Yeah.
Approved.
And what are you going in?
Well, we can do that another time.
Yeah.
So, okay.
So, keep it short films yeah. keep it moving.
Short notes, I'll have recipes for you.
So when you book the trip, I think I was like,
"Oh man, I should catch up on some Rich Roll."
And I listened to some whatever guests
you'd had at the time, but I got into the, the Roll-On.
Yes.
So there's a lot of jokes that'll be set at this table,
but I'm like a fan of the Roll-On.
And not knowing much,
I think because I wanted to brought with you
and I basically loved the show.
I was like, I just kind of off the cuff was like,
on the air during our podcast in Minneapolis, I think,
"I said, I want that guy's job."
And we both laughed about it.
And then like, it didn't go well
because you have so many fans, so many fans.
The roots of this go back a little bit further
because we did that live show in Los Angeles.
And that was the pilot to what we were intending
to be this multi-city tour.
So I was gonna take the podcast on the road,
and I was like, I need kind of like a high energy MC dude,
like hype man to get the crowd up on its feet
and all of that.
And I thought of you immediately.
I was like, oh, Brogan, I should take Brogan on the road.
That's like perfect for what he does.
So we had talked about trying to find a way
to work you into that.
So, I think that was the original seed that was planted
that gave you the gumption to think like,
I'm gonna exploit this.
I'm gonna sneak in.
I'm gonna find some backpack-
Because I'm kind of a low energy hype man.
I'm not a high energy hype man.
It's all hype man.
But I am a hype man.
You are a hype man.
And the reason your job is secure
just to like cut to the finish line here is,
Adam fires on all cylinders.
He can bring the funny,
but he also has the journalism background,
he's got the environmentalism background,
he's a guy who is, you know, studied in words,
not that you're not Brogan, but he's multidisciplinary
and you know, sort of free diving fetish aside.
Yeah.
It works pretty well.
Yeah. That's swim snorkel.
The fact is-
Odd stroke.
One thing that this gentleman does really well-
And he is competed in swim run, which you have not.
I have done it, Casco Bay.
Oh, you did.
Oh.
Let's go.
We'll get there in a second.
But I will say, one thing that I've noticed that you done
on the Roll-On, and that is like a compliment,
storm we're about to have, this'll be over soon.
Is that you both know the things you love,
and that you continue to touch on mostly every show.
(Adam laughing)
But then you also joke about it.
Yes.
Which I think is like missing in the world.
Is like, the passionate kind of dorky things,
everyone has their thing, and they wanna drive it
into every conversation, swim, run,
whatever, whatever, whatever, whatever these things are.
Sharks.
But I appreciate it, and you do this too,
when then you kind of step across the street
and like make fun of it a little bit.
Have a little self-awareness.
Yeah.
Anyway, I think that's one of the brilliant parts
of Roll-On.
'Cause you can say, all right,
I'm gonna do this swimmer on thing,
I can't help it here we go.
And you're like, no, don't do it.
And you're like, you make the joke and then,
and then you do it.
Right?
So it's like, that to me, that frame up is beautiful
of like, I can't help it.
I'm obsessed with this dorky thing.
And here-
If you swim and run as poorly as I do,
you can't take yourself seriously when you do it,
but you can still love to do it.
And you still care about doing it.
Right.
The best part of me being on this show
has been the motivation from Rich to actually take it
even more strategically, which is a lot of fun.
I mean, it's great to be sitting down with you guys.
I mean, you guys are real athletes.
I'm like the every man that's the other thing I think
I can bring is the every man, kind of like,
you guys are real athletes, like college D1 athletes.
I am, what's the opposite of that?
I dunno.
Non D1 athlete.
I think at the shared age and stage we're all in life,
I think we're all just trying to put it out there everyday.
Yeah, but still.
But I think it's easy to put,
like when you see someone on the,
so I'm kind of the every man
who's just doing the best he can.
And so I think there's that too, so yeah.
We'll, just to plant a quick flag at this interim stage
in our therapy session,
I would say that despite the fact that that Brogan
kind of flew here just to trample on the Viceroys kingdom
a little bit and like, you know,
like in a kind of pee on the fire hydrant-
Knock on the door.
Yeah. That this therapy session is going quite well.
I think so.
Right?
I think so. I wish I had an iPad.
Everyone seems to have an iPad.
We gotta throw a wrench in it a little bit.
It gets complicated.
Oh my God.
Oh no.
Are we gonna go there?
Am I gonna get beat up?
No, maybe.
I'm fine with it.
It's two on one.
I mean you're tall, but like two guys on one.
Look, get dead real quick, I can do it.
Fight by your side.
Somebody's gotta film it.
So, it's a love session right now.
We've established that Brogan has some kind of designs
on working his way into this show
and you've been successful.
Here I sit.
You're here right now-
So who's winning?
By sheer force of will.
Even though you guys do-
You still want to win.
It's not about winning, look-
I'm reluctantly giving you an audience,
but here's the thing, like we have jokes about you
sort of making inroads on Adam's fiefdom.
That's one thing it.
This is my fiefdom, it goes from here to here.
So I get these little notches right here.
But in invisible character on Roll-On
in a recurring fashion is Adam's son Zuma.
Mm-mmh.
He's a recurring character.
He is a recurring character.
There's a lot of love for Zuma there.
It's such a Brogan.
Yeah.
I guess we got to do that.
You did just have a daughter?
One month ago.
What is your daughter's name?
Her middle name?
Dramatic pause.
We named our daughter Zuma.
(all laughing)
And my wife, Goldie Graham and I
have this back and forth about names.
She comes home from a walk, pregnant walk,
she's been doing some podcasting,
she walks in the house and says,
not even, Hey, I'm home that she goes,
"What do you think about the name Zuma?"
And because I'm a fan of Rich Roll, and the Roll-On,
and Adam Skolnick, I knew where she had found it.
The thing is, I like the name.
Yes.
And so I didn't want it.
She doesn't know about this posse
or my attempt to join the band.
So I didn't give her the backstory.
I was just like, I love it.
And like, I think a lot of folks do
when they getting ready to have kids,
you play with the name for a week
and then it maybe doesn't make the top of the list
and it goes away and it stayed on the top of the list.
So I reached out to Rich and I was like,
"Dude, this is happening."
And then I think a few, maybe like a month later,
I almost asked for like names-
A month later?
I think so.
Oh, well.
You let that simmer for a month before you picked up.
I send out short films to people every 10 seconds.
About nothing-
Yeah. This is an important thing.
This is beyond short film-
You sit on it for a month.
Because I thought it could fade
and it would be a non-story-
Or you wanted Goldie to come up with some other names
perhaps so you won't have to make that call.
Or I kind of liked the call of this is happening
rather than like, or think we're thinking about it.
So it's like a big re outreach piece.
And Zuma, our little boy is three and a half,
his name is Lumi and people wanna know
what the significance is or where you got it.
It's like in our household,
we just pick names that have a sound and energy to them.
Even if we have to steal them from podcast hosts,
(Rich laughing)
Occasional podcast hosts.
Yeah. Like Robin, you're like Robin to the Batman.
Yeah. I'll take it.
I can be Robin.
I was talking to Skolnick like a few weeks ago
on the phone and I had this shark story
that I had to tell him.
And I was really proud of it.
Because I was in the water and I saw a shark-
Changing the subject.
I know.
We'll get back to it.
I told him about this freaking story.
And I don't know if you remember this,
(Adam laughing)
Do you know this?
I don't know.
I've had paddle on Florida and there was a shark
right next to me.
No I didn't know that.
I told you this.
Okay.
Anyway, well maybe you weren't listening
'cause I told you the story and I was like, I drew it way.
I thought you're kidding.
No, I was serious.
Okay.
It was right next to me in the water.
I looked at the old guys next to me
and they were so unalarmed.
they were just very casual about it.
And I think it was like a five or six foot shark.
And it was like my most epic, adventurous surf story ever.
And I told you on the phone and you were like,
"What kind of shark was it?"
Like you asked the wrong questions
to like take the energy out of it.
And I was like, "Damn"
And I saw your footage and saw, I was like,
you just said the kind thing about us being athletes.
Yeah, I'm not swimming with a shark.
(Adam laughing)
I think you're outta your mind.
You have living in San Diego surfing every day.
But this was like a Reef Shark, and we framed that up,
and then I was like, which kind are you with?
And you swim with white sharks.
So that's a different thing.
But different kinds of sharks over time.
But yeah, you're right about that.
But back to the Zuma, so call me up.
Yes. I call you up.
And I was like, "Look, we're doing this name thing."
Did you call her text?
I think you called, right?
I think it was like a good old fashioned telephone.
That's a call.
Yeah. That's a call subject.
Yeah.
You can text that.
So you're not even FaceTiming.
You're like trying to lock it, you know?
You don't want the face.
I can't look him in the eye when I say this.
Did you find a rotary phone?
Yeah, I did.
(Brogan blowing raspberries)
And then the ones really close,
that's nine.
(Brogan blowing raspberries)
Nine.
Yeah.
And I was like, and I told Adam the story,
what I just told you, Goldie comes back from the walk,
she says, "What do you think?"
And it was like, and he was so nice and laughed
and like was like, "Oh, do it, do it."
Like, I didn't even ask him.
And he was like, "Do it, do it."
You know?
And so I was like, and so I played up this joke
of you didn't have to respond,
but you had some time to give me your blessing.
Right?
I think.
Well, I think the way I looked at it was,
it's already done.
Like, if you wouldn't have called me,
if Goldie hadn't already decided-
Totally. Yeah, exactly.
(Adam laughing)
As if I am driving.
Well, I thought it was funny, but you know,
it landed obviously differently for me than for April.
Right.
But in the end, it's like,
I come from the field of great creative abundance
and nobody owns anything.
And it's great.
I mean, the world, you know, here's how I say it,
the world needs more Zumas.
That's exactly what you said on the phone.
Yeah.
And you said it on a short film as well.
The world needs more Zuma.
It's true.
The world needs more Zumas.
High minded, enlightened response.
What in the backdrop of this dude's questionable motives.
I want his job, didn't get his job,
I guess I'll take his kid's name.
I think there's like-
And here you are anyway.
Where does it end?
How far are we taking this?
You know, what is your podcast do?
What does your podcast do?
I think there's like term for-
What does Zuma like?
Nothing just poops and diapers
and keeps us up on all night.
How's the diaper game?
How's your diaper game?
Yeah.
Was it like that?
Kinda.
Diapers aren't that hard?
Yeah. The diapers aren't that hard.
It's like one thing the dads should just do all diapers.
If you're gonna have a baby,
if you're thinking about having kids, you don't have any,
someone told me, just try and change every diaper,
just cause like, that's a way to contribute.
Like just do every one 'em.
But you're so competitive.
I bet you elbow Goldie out the way to change that diaper.
Get out of the way.
Get out of the way woman.
You know, with a three and a half year old,
you think that you just recently had a baby,
but you're kind of out of practice.
Right?
So, Zuma will wake up in kind of all the hours all night,
and you're like smelling a butt of a tiny little peanut
of a kid.
The kid is the size of my running shoe.
It's cool.
Yeah, it's cool.
And she's really cute and sleeps in the carrier,
and I walk around my neighborhood in Minnesota, it's like,
it's the best, and so-
I've seen some of the neighbors you have there.
Oh, yeah.
No nonsense lawns.
Their lawns are nice.
And then there's a coin flip to be a homeowner
in my neighborhood of like, are you the kind of guy,
person in my case guy, that is doing his own lawn work?
Or are you paying to have someone else do it.
I think you're doing your own?
That's what I think.
I think you gotta do your own.
Yeah.
And then there goes your weekend, I don't know.
And my lawn looks really average.
So I don't know.
I don't know what the answer is, but I'm raking a lot
and mowing and it's just terrible.
I actually mowed the lawn, I made you both a short film,
which I'll send you today, a week or two ago with Zuma
on mowing the lawn with one arm, and making a short film
that says, you all know.
The world needs more Zumas, Rich.
Its a multi-talented dading.
It's a good thing.
Well, on the subject of the world needing more Zumas,
at some point I suspect Zuma A will meet Zuma B,
and what happens-
Zuma boy meets Zuma girl-
What happens when Zuma boy meet Zuma girl
and love flourishes?
That, you know, start planning the wedding, I guess.
The father of the bride-
You're paying.
I'm gonna really keep that low budget though.
'Cause for the environment.
And I'll dance with the daughter and I'll cry a lot
while you're down the aisle.
I getting ready to come here and have this in-person Zuma
conversation debunking some of the,
I want your job still kind of stuff.
Right.
Can I do the gift thing?
Sure.
Oh yeah.
I had a friend of mine who was an artist
in San Diego commission a couple of handmade shirts
that say Zuma's dad.
That's great.
So I'm gonna give it to you right now.
All right.
You don't have to put it on, does he?
I'll put it on.
You have to put it on.
Like I said, and if the first one doesn't fit you,
you can have the other one, and I'll put mine on too.
Let's put them both on.
Let me get them.
So why don't we take quick break while you guys do that.
And while we-
Exchange jerseys?
Right back.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snack a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly, and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say is,
the Plant Power Meal Planner.
Are affordable, all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access to thousands
of highly customizable, super delicious and easy to prepare
plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people,
for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code, RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Look at that.
Look at that, colorful?
Oh, just look, it's one of my favorite tie and dyes.
It's like it's as if you,
it was embroidered upon my Ben and Jerry's tie and dyes.
Now we're back, Zuma's dad.
Dude.
That's an incredible shirt.
It's a great shirt.
For people that aren't watching on YouTube,
it's a hand-sewn, I don't know what you would call it.
I'm a little worried that it's not up to code
for my Ben and Jerry's shift, 'cause I just got hired back.
It has a definite Ben and Jerry's vibe to it though.
Yeah, shimmy, she's doing the upcycled fabrics
and kind of vintage stuff and she's just a crafty
one woman army.
Her name's Dawn, Dawn by the Bay.
Dawn by the Bay.
She makes shirts.
Thank you.
Brogan is wearing a hoodie.
Let me see the back of that hoodie.
Yeah Zuma's dad.
Zuma's dad.
Actually we could start like a group.
Like we should see how many Zuma's dads are out there.
Well, who's Gwen Stefani's-
Baby daddy.
Yeah.
I don't know the answer to that.
It's not Blake.
Right. But we should invite Blake.
Her kid is called Zuma also?
Yeah.
So she has a, what?
A seven year old or something.
I don't even know age.
Named Zuma.
Zuma. So Goldie, they called, there was two calls, right.
You called me and then you called me with Goldie,
and Goldie said, where'd you get the name, right?
Did you get it from Gwen or something like that?
Right.
And I said, no, we got it.
You know, we were married.
I think your audience knows we were married
at that Point Dume.
We were looking at different names.
Zuma means or we've we researched it and Zuma as abundance
and Chumash, which were the native indigenous people
to Malibu from Point Dume up towards Santa Barbara.
Point Dume was sacred in that culture.
And so we kind of borrowed that and we borrowed
some middle names from different places
that were meaningful to us.
So I explained that to you guys, right?
And then, and here we are.
Zuma's dad.
Yeah.
Well, I've done this with Rich over the years
and you and I have exchanged a little bit
over the last month, my Zuma's been alive for a month,
but like the, you know, trading dad advice,
it's the real thing.
I think more dudes need to be out there
just talking about the good, bad and the ugly,
because the good stuff is really, really great,
and I think that that's kind of like a missing thing.
So, yeah.
We've had those conversations,
we've had those conversations,
and I think that stuff's really powerful,
especially for dads that are on the beginning of the-
Beginning dads, when it's not-
I've got a buddy right now who's like in the first,
he's like six weeks in and you know, he's starting like...
It's like you see, like...
And like listen, he's older as two.
So he didn't have these illusions
of how it was supposed to be.
But at the same time it's like,
coming to terms with what your life is
and where it exists in the nature of this, you know,
24 hour a day.
Where does your life fit in that 24 hour day
is a matrix, right?
And it changes.
And it's always shifting.
I mean, for me, like,
I'm so happy to have the time change back to like,
I used to love daylight savings time,
but now like during daylight savings hours,
I haven't been outside in the night
more than like two or three times
and seeing the sun go down, right?
You know, cause that's bedtime period, you know?
And now, I'm happy it's getting dark at like 4:50
in the afternoon because that means I get to be outside
when it's night.
It's not like I was a huge night owl all my life,
but for a good chunk, I definitely love being out at night.
And I loved full moon hikes and things like that.
And some of that has been the first year
for specially for six, nine months, that's off the table.
You can't even really figure it out.
And so to me, what you get back,
you win back the dawns, right?
So you're up early and especially I do the breakfast disco
with him, and I don't have the nights, but I get the dawns.
And that's when I used to admire like seeing Rich,
like do his stories, like getting his coffee going
at like before five, and I would be getting up
at eight and like, who are these motherfuckers
that are running at five in the morning?
Like why am I so late?
And then I think I listened to-
Well necessities dictates that when you have kids,
you gotta get organized.
And you find where your life exists, right?
You find the margin you still have.
And you can't give in to, I don't have,
or you can't examine your life in the prism
of what you used to have.
Totally.
You have to accept life and find your space to still,
you know, do your thing in a way that's good for everybody.
So, it's a challenge, but it's fun in that regard.
And you know, you just got to commit to the choice
you've already made, basically.
The idea of a newborn for me using that margins ideas
like retired folks golf all day, like hang out,
go by and go to the pool, huge margins,
almost completely margins.
Whereas mine is thin or non-existent or when it's alive
or around inside a 24 hour period, it is shifty,
it is a moving target, it could just pop up out of nowhere,
or it could be canceled.
So, as someone who moves and needs to be out in the world,
in Minneapolis, you saw firsthand like communicating
with people like the banter, the interactions like and sport
and training and yoga.
So like, that has been a very selfish thing
that dads shouldn't complain about, but it's real.
You start losing yourself in some of that stuff.
So, I've told both of you,
but like falling into a new yoga practice has been huge
because you can unroll that mat at two in the morning,
two in the afternoon, whatever,
and it's a little bit of escapism in a way
that I think is actually healthy.
Yeah.
Well, escapism is very, like I don't understand people
who are against escapism.
Have you seen what's going on in the world?
(all laughing)
It's just a matter of what's your escape
and is it productive?
I think we've kind of teed off into this big topic issue
that we wanted to talk about, which is, you know,
being a dad and what does that mean?
I had put all this other stuff in the outline that I wanted
to talk about, but since we're kind of going there,
we should probably just do it now,
but I think it would be good to just put a cap
on the therapy session aspect of this.
And I feel like you guys are broing out and it's all good,
there's nothing but love here-
Thank you.
And respect.
Can you, put another hand on top of-
Despite the bum rush?
Look how tan you are.
I think this is all for the best.
Thank you Rich.
It was a shock.
It was a shock to see the white tiger in the space.
The silky white tiger.
You got new clothes out of it?
Your job is super secure-
For him absconding with your son's name
and appropriating it for his own purposes.
Can't get the job-
That was (foreign language) appropriation bra.
(all laughing)
It's also cool to hear Rich Roll,
tell like a billion fans and listeners like,
his job is secure, he said it a million times.
That's good.
Yeah. Just so we're totally clear,
to all the Skolnick-nights out there.
Here we go.
Adam's job is very secure.
Let's talk about ads.
Yeah. Ads, I think there's a little opportunity.
I have not been moving product.
Just giving you some discount codes and I am just-
When we're done today, we're gonna bank a bunch of ads.
Yeah. Oh, you want to know about macro bars?
Take this discount code.
Call me later.
Right?
I think you should make every ad about sex.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like take the most mundane ad, like,
like one of those Roca ads.
Right, right, right.
Keep going.
Make it about sex vision.
Oh, okay.
You want to perform better in the bedroom?
Don't wanna do the pill?
Yeah.
Athletic greens.
(Adam laughing)
I'm taking control of this-
Sorry, sorry.
We gonna switch gears, I do have a couple announcements
I need to make the first of which is,
I wanna let everyone know that we're putting together,
we're compiling this end of the year listener stories,
very special afterschool special version of the podcast.
I love that.
I love that idea.
So what we're doing is we're kind of soliciting all of you
guys out there, the listeners to share your personal story
of how this show has impacted you, how it's benefited you,
how it has, you know, reoriented your personal views
or your worldview, how it's inspired you to kind of reframe
your vision of family,
which we're gonna talk more about today.
Work, sense of self, all of that stuff.
You know how it has acted as an agent of change
in your own personal evolution.
So, if you have been impacted and you're willing to share,
it would mean a lot if you could give us a call
at 805 421-0057, and just kind of lay it all out
in a long voicemail, your journey of transformation,
how the podcast and all of the guests that we've had on
have inspired you, what you've learned,
what you've practiced, what you've implemented
or share with others along the way,
and we're gonna take all that and we're gonna create
something really cool with it.
So, again, 805 421 0057.
Brogan I expect you to leave a voicemail.
I've been leaving voicemails.
You've been doing that for a while.
I tired sneaking on the ritual-
Second thing is-
Rich I'd like to just come right out and say,
I'm available to help with the listener story,
compilation curation.
I'm also available with Dan Drake.
You can do it with Dan and Drake-
We can do some interviews,
I can help conduct some interview.
Oh that would be good.
Like, oh, that's a good one.
I'm gonna call that guy and go deeper
and press him or her.
Yes.
Maybe we could do that.
And if there's a way we could bring ads into this,
that'd be cool.
Yeah.
We'll bring Brogan in as the ad guy.
Sounds like is a good place for some ads, guys.
Can we deep fake Brogan or do I have to work
with the actual Brogan?
Guys, I don't know, he knows Zuckerberg.
So, back to the metaverse.
I'll be foiling with Zuck.
I'm gonna be foiling with the deep fakes out Zuck.
Not real Zuck.
A comment about that in a second,
but first my second announcement,
I wanna let everyone know that I'm gonna be speaking
at the upcoming planted expo in Vancouver on November 20th
and 21st looking to be a super cool event.
Canada's largest plant-based event
with tons of great speakers.
My boy, John Lewis, bad-ass vegans gonna be there,
tons of exhibitors attendees,
there's also this kind of intimate dinner with me
on the evening of November 20th.
I think we're gonna do some kind of live podcast
around that as well.
So, if you're in Vancouver or nearby
or willing to travel there, I look forward to seeing you
and you can learn more and get your tickets@plantedlife.com.
I'm available to help carry your bags that evening.
You wanna do that?
Second thing is on the subject of foiling and Zuckerberg,
Adam and I, since it's been a while,
since we've done the Roll-On or like what happened-
Bout a month, right?
Yeah. Maybe like six weeks, I think, a lot-
Six weeks, September 30th, right?
Yeah. That was the last time that we've done this.
So a ton of stuff has happened, too many things to recap.
But one thing that we gotta talk about is that,
Adam and I both got invited to go to Surf Ranch up
in central California, which is Kelly Slater's, you know,
epic wave pool.
And it was an event that was put together by Red Bull media,
they invited all these cool people to go and spend the day
and having a pretty amazing experience to be up there,
because we were surrounded by all these pro surfers like,
pro surfers, when they get the nod, like,
hey, come out to the Surf Ranch, they show up.
Because the wave is insane, and it's the same every time
and they can work on very specific things
that they're working on.
So, Adam and I being like most mediocre surfers ever.
That's being kind, that's being very kind, in my stead.
We get there and they go through this whole instructional
thing and then there's heats, like, you go out for an hour,
you come back and then he goes out of like eight people.
And originally I thought my heat wasn't gonna be
until like 11:00 AM or something like that.
And it's like 6:45 and they're like,
"Oh, Rich, you're going in seven, you're the first heat."
And like, I've never been in a wave pool,
like I haven't surfed in like a decade, you know?
And they're putting me out there with like Kai Lenny
and like these other guys, and I'm freaking out
like thinking I'm gonna get in their way,
I'm gonna screwing them up and all that kind of stuff,
I was like, almost had a panic attack.
What I'm doing here, you know?
But it ended up being like an incredible experience
just to like, hang out with all these people and talk story.
I loved it.
What was your experience?
Wow. Same.
You know, like I haven't been on a board in over a decade
and I'm comfortable swimming around in the ocean
and it would have been comfortable even at that size.
It's a fast wave that comes at you.
But like, being put on this big board
and feeling very clumsy,
I was definitely afraid I was gonna get in someone's way
and like, you know, hurt people.
And then after that, I was like also afraid to surf
in front of these wonderful surfers.
I thought they would put guys like us
all out in the scene, like why are they mixing us up
with real guy-
The rookie class, go out there and hurt each other.
But I mean, it was also really cool
to able to see Kai like blazing down this.
And he did a front flip.
I literally did a flip 360 right in front of me
and did a flip off the lip of the wave.
That guy is incredible.
I know.
And Sky Brown, 13 year old skateboarding medalist,
and she shredded, she could easily-
I didn't know who she was and she was in my heat
and Raimana.
Raimana.
Sorry I always get his name wrong.
Who's like an epic waterman is out there,
cruising around on a jet ski to like,
make sure everyone's cool and helping out the newbies
like Adam and I, and I was paddling right next to her
and he didn't know who she was either.
And he's like, she's 13,
she's this little girl with a big smile.
And he's like, "Hey, you know, do you know how to surf?
Like, what's your deal?
Like, are you okay?"
And she's like, "Oh, well, you know, I'm okay,"
or whatever.
She picks up a wave and just shreds it.
Like I've never seen in my life.
And then I find out it's not her best sport.
No, she literally won a bronze medal in Tokyo
in skateboarding.
And she's 13.
Like this girl is the future of adventure sports.
I met her in Minneapolis when we first moved in 2019,
Minneapolis was home for a lot of years in a row
of the X games for the Summer Games.
She was there, you know, two years ago, 11 years old
and tiny and just incredibly talented.
And we had a really cute moment where,
I was babysitting this kid,
kinda like a nephew type kid in my life.
And he kind of whispered, he kind of elbowed me.
He's like, "there she is, that's her."
And I did like kind of the dorky uncle thing of like,
let's go meet her.
Yeah.
And like, he was mortified, but like I sat him up,
made him take the picture.
And then he has just been parading this photo ever since.
It's like it's his idol.
She's his idol.
It's really beautiful.
For good reason, man.
She is amazing.
Absolutely.
And Raimana Van Bastolaer, I think is his last name,
he's basically the mayor of Teahupoo
You know, he like is the guy there
and he's a Tasian surf legend,
and he is the head of the safety crew.
And so I think he must have been tapped by Kelly
or someone to like come and actually run.
So he runs the pool,
when he's out there, he's calling the waves,
he's calling positions for all the safety guys,
which are all great surfers in their own, right.
And then he's helping people like Sky get barreled,
figuring them out.
He's you know, making the pros feel comfortable.
They're getting what they need.
And then he's literally picking up likes of me and Rich
and making sure we get a wave.
And so like helping us get up and giving us tips, and-
My first time out,
he's like jump on the back of the jet ski with your board,
and like the complexity of the situation just went through.
I'm like, I'm supposed to jump off a jet ski onto the wave.
Like it's hard enough just to catch it for me.
Did you ride waves?
Yeah.
You caught some wave?
So they sent us all this video,
'cause they video, everything.
And it's, you know, it's like, you know,
a middle-aged guy riding a, you know,
a gigantic board and very mediocre wave.
And I was like, that's cool.
No one really needs to see that.
(all laughing)
That accidentally disappears.
And that's even better than what I have, but yeah.
I mean, I've managed it.
In a beautiful, kind of full circle, you know,
kind of reassess your life kind of way though.
Like, first of all, just to be invited there,
was incredible.
You can't just go there like it's, I think it's 50,000 a day
to rent the place and that it's usually corporate events.
Its booked out like years in advance.
It's very special to even have that experience.
So we were incredibly privileged to have that,
but Raimana goes way back with my guy,
Mike Field who's who is an epic Hawaii Waterman,
who has been my swim crew captain
for all of the ultramarine that I've done.
So every time I go to Hawaii, I hook up with him
and he's the guy who's guided me through those races.
And Mike and Raimana are super close.
And in addition to that,
another guy who was on this trip was my friend,
Chris Weiler, who runs a production company
here in LA called Dirty Robber,
and he does a lot of Red Bull media stuff,
but he was on my crew for my first ultramarine.
Like we're really good friends in LA.
So to like, and I didn't know that he was going,
it's like, I don't see him that often.
I hadn't seen him in a long time and we got to like ride
waves together and talk about how our lives have grown
and changed since that experience in 2008,
that changed my life.
And it's just really cool.
That's awesome.
And you know, to put a cap on the whole Raimana thing,
I just found it, his story really captivating
and loved hanging out with him and the Surf Ranch also,
what's interesting about it really is this five star
kind of experience, but it's in the middle of like
the central valley is yeah, it's in the middle.
It's like 45 minutes from Fresno or something like that.
Or 40 miles from Fresno.
Anybody who's driven, the five freeway
from LA to San Francisco knows how desolate
it gets in the middle of that section.
So imagine you're in the most desolate center
of that whole experience.
And then you exit the five freeway and then go inland,
you go east for another 35 minutes or so,
and there's nothing there except like this oasis
of bright...It was dark when I was driving in,
the night before and suddenly like in the middle
of like farm land, there's this huge casino.
And you go in there and it's the most like depressing
breaking bad situation you've ever seen,
but that's the only hotel.
So that's where all the surfers stay.
That's where everyone stays,
was like kind of everyone was at the bar,
like kind of having food and getting to know each other
the night before.
And it was just bizarre,
but it's like five minutes from the ranch.
And you go to the ranch in the morning.
I was reading "Pastoral Song" at that time.
So it's like all the breakdown of what's happened
in terms of industrial agriculture,
and you've talked about regenerative agriculture
on your show many times,
and it shows you the opposite of that like the reason
regenerative agriculture agriculture needs to work is that,
when industrial agriculture takes over an area,
it's bigger is the only way to succeed,
and so it crowds out all the people.
And so there's no jobs there really.
It's not like you don't need as many farm heads, you know,
it's all mechanized and the towns are crumbling.
I took a run around just to see it and experience it.
And then to go to, you know, at the time I was like,
why is the Surf Ranch out here?
But then going and experiences,
I'm glad the Surf Ranch is there
because it gives a lot of people.
A lot of people are having the same experience that we had
is like, wow, you know, there's something not working.
You know, like, there's something about our culture,
that's profoundly not working.
Right.
And you do see it there.
And so to me you could look at that,
maybe you don't want to see that,
but I actually think when you get those glimpses
that you're not expecting,
it's really could be really important.
And so I thought that was interesting caveat to that.
And then the other thing is Raimana said,
he surfs with all the curvatures that come through.
So he has surfed many times with Zuckerberg.
That's why we're teeing it up.
We're bringing it back to Zuckerberg
formally because Zuckerberg will rent it out for the day.
There's like a base nearby,
that's used to fly your private jet or whatever in.
And he comes in in the morning with his wife
and they just take it over for the whole day
and then fly back home.
And Raimana says, he's quite good,
which is really upsetting to hear.
I did not like it.
You don't want that.
(Adam laughing)
You want this whole story about a guy dropping 50K
once a week.
And he sucks.
(Adam laughing)
Well, he probably wasn't good at first,
but if you can fly up to Surf Ranch
get unlimited waves for an entire day.
The learning curve gets shrunk considerably.
Welcome back, Mark.
How's the weekend.
Okay, here it is again.
We'll just leave it on.
Set it at six, have at it.
Yeah. And the way the wave works,
I mean, it is a genius feed of engineering.
'Cause there's literally this locomotive engine
that pushes this wall of water back and forth
and it goes back and forth.
So the waves go both ways, and they figured out
how to dissipate the water so that it calms down
super quickly in between waves in a way that is remarkable.
Oh that's cool.
And the wave is just unbelievable.
Yeah, its fast and you know,
we were even paddling into like the contest waves
at one point they had us doing, didn't you come out of there
with like a bruise rib.
I had like fin slices on both legs.
I had like a fractured, I still dealing with it.
I like cracked a rib.
Which I can like run and swim
and it doesn't really bother me.
But something about surfing and pushing up on the board
was like, yeah, it was-
And if you're out of the water for a while,
when you get back on and paddle,
you're gonna have those-
I surfed A lot in college,
and I literally felt like I'd never surfed in my life.
And then just like on a technical thing,
do you have any issues with the swim snorkel mask
while you catch away?
I didn't bring it.
Oh, no way.
I don't know why.
Well, I wanted to swim in there,
but I didn't wanna get in the way,
like I wanted to be polite.
Like it's not about me swimming in your wave-
Like can you shut the waves off
I gotta use them some meters.
So, I just turned 55 and Adam gifted me
the best birthday gift.
He literally got me a snorkel mask.
All my efforts to get him off the mask.
And what does he do?
Just trying to get me on the mask.
Here we go.
(Adam laughing)
I mean-
This is happening.
You have to, you just have to.
Let me get something.
I have something too.
It's too loose right now, but you get the idea.
And then yeah, then you drop-
Your prescription lenses on this.
You go right to the end of the lane,
you drop your pool buoys, and-
Right. You surf with this though, right?
That's the idea.
Totally.
I got myself a new one.
Here we go.
Adam goes out and swims in the ocean
with this on rather than swimming goggles.
Well, I don't quite use that.
I got you a better one than what I used.
I would only use that in a dive scenario.
I wouldn't swim with that.
But if you come with us back to the brief,
bring that this next time, and then we can dive around.
You guys got iPads and glasses and goggles.
I'm just going shades.
Ah, yeah.
This mask is like, got its own following.
I got this mask.
It's called the devil.
Yeah, it's like the devil mask.
I got this at Sylvia Earle's dive shop.
Wow.
If you went up to see Sylvia Earle's
and she's still on her podcasts.
Right, right.
I'm excited about that.
She's just gonna be amazing.
And she has a dive shop in a ramshackle submarine factory.
It's fucking awesome.
It's an Alameda, California.
And so I got a new one for me 'cause I got that for you,
and I wanted to bring it.
Good, man.
Well, there was a bunch of other stuff that happened,
but is it all that important?
I feel like we should talk about.
I think we should talk about daddying.
Dad life.
Father's Day's coming up.
Father's Day is always just-
When is Father's Day?
It's in June.
(Adam laughing)
It's in June, I do a countdown.
I got a ticker.
I have a ticker in my lawn.
But in Nova Scotia it's in November.
Right, right, right.
And Nova Scotia father's day.
Yeah. Its always father's day somewhere.
It's like the father o'clock-
I celebrate Icelandic Father's Day on Jan seven.
Oh cool.
Yeah.
To Reykjavik.
Reykjavik Father's Day.
Before we do that though,
should we have a little running news?
Let's do it.
'Cause it was a big weekend.
Huge.
We had the LA marathon,
we have the New York city marathon.
Same day, right?
And our own in-house boy, David Greenberg himself
ran his first marathon LA marathon-
Davy!
Wearing his finishing, come on over here Davy.
Davy, get over here.
You don't have to wear a mask-
Mask's optional.
Ran under four hours in his first marathon.
While nursing an injury.
And having a little bit of a janky knee
that took him out of some of the training.
So, David just give us 30 seconds.
Okay. 30 seconds go.
It was hard.
It was really fun.
You know, did it alongside going plant-based
for the first time it was really like a great test
and I feel good.
I feel accomplished.
I feel like really grateful.
All my friends came out like so many people
were so supportive.
We raised a bunch of money and yeah,
I can't wait for the next one.
Big Sur, April 24.
You get a little bit of arrest
and then you're gonna hit it hard.
But you train really hard.
I feel like you trained really methodically.
But what I saw was someone who was having like so much fun,
like you went from nothing and then hearing Hellah
and getting inspired to getting pretty focused
and serious pretty quickly.
And it took you on like a journey.
Like you're a different guy than you were
before Hellah came on the podcast.
I definitely, and also like it's one of those things
where people talk about like the love, hate relationship
with running all the time.
And that wasn't my experience, I just loved it.
Like I think it's one of the most enjoyable things
I've discovered.
And I just have like so much fun doing it.
Like it doesn't, it hurts,
but like it doesn't hurt in a way that is discouraging
and yeah.
It's just like really excited to have discovered this thing.
Yeah.
It's cool, man.
And I feel like you also used it to broaden your community.
Like you got involved in all these run clubs,
the Korean Run club and the Besties and all of that,
and ended up making all these friends out of the process.
And the ritual pod crew, yeah.
It made me think.
And I should say that, you know,
in addition to you running the marathon,
like Blake and Jason have been running quite a bit,
Jason's on his run streak.
Jason, how many days have you won?
127.
127 days of running every single day since Hellah.
I mean, Hellah, is really the catalyst.
I'm pretty sure I know.
I'm pretty sure you have a big part in it too, right?
Well, I just get the host these people
and then get to see the ripple effects of their message.
But Jason having his run streak and then the three of you
guys ran that trail half marathon together,
which like warm my heart to see you guys
doing that together.
Blake has been swimming, Adam, Blake and Jason
are doing the Malibu Half so, it's been really cool.
And it's made me think that there's gotta be a way to kind
of expand the scope of this to make it kind of a more open
community oriented thing.
So maybe in 2022, I've always resisted this idea
of like creating a group run or a run club
or something like that,
'cause I never know how much, you know,
like my friends are always like, let's go riding.
And for me it's always a solo thing.
Like I know Brogan is like,
it's all about the group in November project.
And for me it's like, I'm the lone wolf.
Like I resist it.
But I think in the wake of COVID and all the isolation
that we've experienced and just when I went into the group
run in Central Park for the FAR event and all of that,
like it's so much fun.
And so if we can find a way to maybe create something
like that here, where maybe once a month we do a trail run,
a Chesbro or something that's near here, you know,
and make it open to people, you know,
we can call it like the fire club
or something like that.
It would be cool.
That's sweet.
Let's make it happen.
Yeah. And you guys can,
and the fact that because all you guys are running,
like then it's not all on me.
Like we can have like, you know, sergeants and generals
to help manage it if I'm out of town or something.
All right. I'm escaping.
Thank you Rich.
Congrats man.
You're really an inspiration.
Yeah. Thank all you guys.
It cool to see you out there too,
to give you a hug, right?
Also in other running news, I mean,
we got to mention a couple standouts from the weekend.
Shalane Flanagan friend of the pod ran 233
for her six consecutive marathon in six weeks.
Unreal.
Unbelievable.
233 crazy.
Her fastest one yet.
So that's amazing.
I mean, I had so much FOMO watching the New York marathon.
It's terrible watching that starting line is like,
looking up that bridge.
There's Knox, there's Robin Arzon
R's on there's Alexi Pappas who like another great story
she starts with the elites,
but she's had some injuries,
so she wasn't in it to like, you know, hammer.
She just wanted to have fun,
but because she started with the elite,
she had her name on the thing and the whole thing.
And then she just turned it into this like 26.2 mile party
where she was blowing kisses to people the whole way
and just became this crazy fan favorite.
Oh man, she's so great for running.
And for that event, for those of you who have run it
to be in the five boroughs
and to have each of those ecosystems come to life
in a different way,
to see her going through those different stages.
Right.
And to see her fans everywhere.
I know.
I mean, she's incredible.
She had glitter all over herself, you know,
and just turned it into like a performance art.
Awesome.
You've run in New York, right?
I did New York, I've done Boston a couple of times
and a handful of other ones.
Yeah. What'd you run in New York?
I ran.
(Brogan laughing)
I'm gonna make you say it.
I ran 302 in New York.
Yeah.
It was my quickest one.
And then maybe a race or two later.
I haven't done the road thing for a while.
So we did some years on the trail.
And then, yeah, I'm doing a lot of yoga man,
when I see, I mean, knowing what you went through on Sunday,
you know, that starting line looking up that bridge,
it's just so cool.
And thinking about like every step,
getting you closer to Central Park.
I did LA.
Oh you did LA.
Well, I guess you gotta get to New York.
Seeing in New York, I was like.
Oh my gosh.
I need some of that energy in my life.
It starts, yeah, yeah.
Our boy Knox making 240 look easy.
Ripped it up.
He looks like he's strolling.
It looks like he's walking in the mall.
I know, stopping to say hi, kiss babies, and then like,
oh, he's probably running like a 345.
330 effort.
And then he comes into like,
he seems to always land into 230s.
I know.
(Rich laughing)
Like, how do you do that?
Have you seen me run by as fast as I can.
I look like I'm in pain?
Like, I look like I'm working for it.
He's just floating.
Knox is amazing.
But I have to say, I think the performance
that impacted me the most was Tommy Rivs.
After his bout with cancer showed up walk the whole thing.
It took him nine hours and 19 minutes.
There's a beautiful New York Times article
in the Paper Today written by Adam's editor, right?.
Yeah, Talya Minsberg who runs,
endurance and adventure sports
kind of for the sports desk there,
and is a kind of more often than not my editor.
And she's obviously gifted reporter and she ran
the marathon as well.
So there's like some video,
(indistinct chattering)
Yeah, yeah. I mean they both,
they kind of go back and forth.
Right, right.
He's a great runner too.
But it's a beautiful piece and must read stuff
about Tommy and what he went through.
And then the fact that he went to walk this
and he considered that this greatest accomplishment
and his post, which is just so poetic and so beautiful
and kind of talks about unity and love.
And it's exactly kind of what we need all need to read
right now, which you shared, I think.
Yeah, I did.
And I was on the receiving end of a lot of messages saying
you got to get this guy on the podcast,
and we recorded a couple of weeks ago.
And, I think I was remiss in not releasing that podcast
today, being today, being Monday, November 8th, you know,
the day after the marathon, I should have done that.
If I had been thinking about things more clearly
that would have been obviously the time
to share that conversation.
It's not gonna publish until,
and you didn't know that he had been here.
I didn't even know he'd been here-
A couple of weeks ago.
I usually like keep it under wraps,
like who I've talked to until it's time to release it.
But I just wanna let everyone know that we had
an incredible conversation.
I think you guys are gonna really love it.
He's such a beautiful human,
but it's not gonna go up until mid.
I think it's going up in mid December.
Whenever it happens.
It's perfect.
'Cause you know, he's also got a good message
for like new years or for rebooting how you look
at the world.
So, you know, I think.
Yeah. We have to shout out a couple other friends,
the risk with doing this is I'm gonna leave somebody out
of course, I think I mentioned Robin Arzon,
but my boy Dan Churchill ran 328, Brian Levine 254,
under three Chris Chavez, he's an expert 334,
friend Steve Barr, Daniel Hume, friend of the pod.
I think he ran like three hours or something close to it.
You guys know?
Wow.
Reese Robinson who used to do a bunch of work
for the podcast video and photography stuff ran.
I think it was his first marathon.
We also talked about Knox and then Oz, the mentalist.
Yeah. Oz, the mentalist.
He's a magician.
I don't know who this guy is.
He does like he's, do you know who he is?
No.
He's been featured on ESPN a bunch of times.
He goes mostly does speaking gigs and kind of corporate
stuff, but he's a, this really gifted magician basically.
And he could give you one card out of a deck of 52
and you could swear, he'd never would have seen it.
And he's even done this on Zoom
and he knows he can tell you what it is.
And it's not just card tricks.
It's like, he can tell you the numbers on the dollar bill
that was in your wallet.
Like the dollar bill you took out of your own wallet.
Right.
He can guess the numbers on it right on, on Zoom.
So like that kind of stuff.
That's like, he is wild like that.
And I don't know him that well,
I've talked to him a couple of times.
He's connected to David Goggins,
and as David's had run with him a few times
and knows him pretty well and Oz did 229 came in 33rd place.
He's in his 40s.
That's wild.
He's got three kids, talking about dad life-
229 is no joke.
That's no joke dude.
He's got some margins.
He has two kids?
Three.
Three kids?
Three kids, young kids.
All right. So time to level up.
No kidding, right?
I'm over here. Like I found time to do yoga.
I'm pretty sure he's 40.
I mean, he could be late 30s,
but he's in that same range.
That's impressive.
Yeah.
That's cool.
So daddying, let's pivot to daddying.
Yeah.
That's great.
Advice for new dads.
I would add her down the line than you guys.
So I can give the 10,000 foot view on this,
but you guys are both in it.
So my heart goes out to you.
I know how hard it is.
And I think it's just to kind of set the tone for this.
I feel like, and this is like a crazy generalization,
but I feel like, you know, new moms or impending moms,
like they know what they're in for,
and like they end up getting-
They study up.
They study harder.
There's a lot of books are involved,
there's a lot of conversations with their friends,
like are prepared as it could possibly be.
And the typical dad is just like,
we'll see how this goes.
(all laughing)
For sure.
Thank God they're studying.
Well, one of us read the books.
That'll be, well,
and then there's the COVID era dad.
That I found when we had Lumi in 2018,
that it was all of those,
and I used to kind of roll my eyes a little bit,
but the appointments that were every month
and then every week, and then seemingly every day
until this kid is born, we're actually the best time for me
as the dad to like re up on how real this was about to be.
And during the COVID era, you can't have,
in most facilities,
they don't allow someone to come to the appointment.
So you take all of that re up and out of it
and the belly gets bigger and you kind of hear that-
I had to do that all remote.
Right.
So then you don't get that reminder of like,
this is happening.
So you're really not changing your mindset.
And then, so then this baby's born.
It's like, oh, right.
So I will say that.
When are they coming to pick it up?
What was the date?
Oh, it's not, oh.
So we're taking this home.
Oh, we're cleared, no background check.
We get this.
Well, there's always right.
There's always that come t Papa moment, right?
Like for me, it happened when we got back April,
like it took her a minute to adjust to the car crash
she just gone through
and her body was like, had gone through the ringer.
And like, she was literally shivering.
Like she was freezing in and she was not even,
didn't even have a fever or anything.
Like she had normal temperature.
And so that happened like the first day we came back
from the hospital.
So then it's like me on point for those couple of days.
So everyone, I think it might come to them
at a different time, the dad is going to have to step up
very early on.
And that to me is the moment where,
the lock-in process happens, you know?
'Cause even if you go through that, this is your second,
so you had that already.
I don't know if you remember when Lumi came,
or Rich, if you remember your moment you had
where you're like, okay, it's my turn.
It's, you know, like all this is real
and it's gonna sink or swim based on my ability
in this very moment, pressure on moment.
And so that happened early on for us and it did lock me in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's not like I even appointed disagree on,
but I feel like the contribution of like the diapers
and the support and, you know,
keeping the house kind of somewhat together and, you know,
bringing the water while she's breastfeeding
and all that you can do work your ass off,
it's still gonna be a fraction of the show
and that she, and the offering and the shared chemicals
and the, and you know,
so, yeah, I mean, vice to dads is like,
someone told me one time change every diaper.
Yeah.
And like, and do as much as you can
and be ready for the fact that it won't really register
on the scale of like actual giving yourself as much-
Right, like acknowledge whatever you're doing
is such a drop in the bucket total to compared
to what she has to handle.
And if you approach it from a perspective of like,
hey, look at me over here, good on being you're toast.
Like it has to be show up, just do all this stuff
and try to anticipate the needs before she even, you know,
can think to ask you to take care of it.
And the more you can be in that head space, the better off.
And you're never gonna be like,
it's about that bond between mom and baby.
And there is a little bit of a powerlessness to it too,
'cause you're like, well, I'm just kind of in the way,
most of the time.
Totally.
Which is good, embrace that.
Because your time's coming.
Yeah. You're like a confused concierge.
The concierge, you're an untrained concierge.
You're a bellhop with no keys.
Like you don't know, that the idea of,
and I wish someone said this to me, the idea of,
and I told your entire crew this, when I rolled up,
we had a moment we're laughing and catching up with Jason,
and the guys.
And it was like, I can imagine someone's gonna hear
what I'm about to say and think like less of me
or somewhat controversial.
But I wish someone would have told me that being the dad
of a baby is a different level of service, fun, excitement,
energy, entertainment, connection,
then the kid that will come from it.
And so a year later the kids learned to walk or two years
later, like there's some personality three years later,
the kids in preschool, like I can say from my experience,
it's awesome being a dad to a kid,
it's a lot of unrewarding work to be a dad to a baby.
And I wish that was a little bit more okay to say
it sounds selfish, but it's-
No, I think the way to frame that,
'cause I hear what you're saying 100%,
there's this idea, this narrative out there
that even if you're on the fence about having kids,
like when the baby comes, there's that lightning bolt moment
and you're struck with.
(indistinct chattering)
And just life is never the same.
And I think like, sort of knowing that kind of gets set
out there.
If you don't have that experience, then you feel like,
well, wait a minute, like, I don't know, like,
why am I, you feel guilty?
You feel like-
Did you have that?
Yes and no.
Like, it wasn't some crazy thing like that.
It was a slower, like boil towards that.
But when the baby is, you know, it's like a ball of goo,
you know, sometimes it can be really hard to connect.
And I think a lot of people struggle
because they don't initially feel that way,
but it's not until they start to, you know,
sort of outwardly exude human characteristics
that then you're like, you see the little personality
or whatever, and the more human they become
and the more individuated they become in their personality,
that's where the love affair can like really take root.
Totally.
So I think if you're not experiencing those emotions
off the bat in the way that you feel like culture
is demanded, that you must,
that you need that you just go easy on yourself
and trust that, you know, just keep doing the thing.
And that will come.
It's about the habit you're building.
It's not about how you're feeling at the moment, right?
Like that's how I feel about almost anything,
but especially with this,
and there are people that I heard that same thing,
you're gonna have, it's gonna be like water hits you,
like a bucket of cold water and your whole life is,
you know, but I think those are for people
that maybe haven't had those experiences in other ways.
And if you've had other experiences where you've kind
of had expansive moments in your life,
I don't know that that's necessarily gonna happen.
Did I shed tears when Zuma came?
Yes. But it was also a very arduous, you know, long process.
And I was also tired.
And I can't say that immediately it's because, you know,
like, you know, this golden light of love hit me
in the heart kind of thing.
I loved him right away,
but I didn't have exactly what you're saying.
I did not have that story book thing.
But at the same time, I didn't really expect it or need it,
you know?
So it's about setting that expectation.
If you think that's gonna happen for you
or you want that to happen for you,
and that's the meaning,
then I think you're kind of looking for something
that isn't going to be lasting anyway.
And so it's about the habit you build,
to me it's about the habit you build, at 14 months, man.
I never knew 14 month, year old kids could be so fun
and full of personality.
And like this stage I'm in now is so far my favorite.
And it's been that way since the beginning, every stage,
every new stage is my favorite stage.
So, and that's a good point.
Yeah.
Which I try and practice as loudly as I can
with either friends that are talking about
one day having kids or friends that are,
maybe your partner is pregnant.
I say to as many dads as possible,
the practice I'm working on is everything.
You know, when your crew says, how tired are you?
How's it going?
If my answer is I'm fucking exhausted, it's a lot.
I make sure to have equal air time,
especially for other potential dads,
I make sure to have an equal airtime for yeah but I put Zuma
on my chest and we walk around, you know,
at night when she can't sleep and it's really cute
and it's warming and it's beautiful
because I think there's this, like,
you can kind of be in a cycle with like the diapers,
man fuck.
And like, it's just so hard, it kinda sucks, right.
And I even, I just said it five minutes ago,
the baby doesn't give a lot back.
It's okay, if you'd like kids, but not babies.
It's like, I make, I try these days to like also do
the kind of the cheesy mushy lovey stuff.
And I think that's a good practice for men to be like,
and it's the cutest shit ever too.
And it's better than running the LA marathon
a million times.
Like it's not like anything.
And just trying to give like this epic, you know,
description of like how much better life is,
your boy Casey said, he's like,
"It's the best thing I've ever done.
I got to have a big life."
He's like, he said it this morning,
"It's the best thing he's ever done."
And he said like, he tells as many people as possible.
Yeah. And I just think it's important to, you know,
create that opening or that space for guys to talk about it.
For sure.
Women don't have a problem with this by large,
but guys are sorta like, who do I call?
Or like, am I allowed to talk about that?
Like, one of the things that I appreciate about you Brogan
is you're always like, how's the dad stuff what's going on.
Like when we talk, it's like right too.
Like, what's the important thing that, you know,
maybe you can't, you don't feel as comfortable sharing
with your wife or some of your friends that don't have kids
and creating like that space for dads to talk about like
what they're going through with their kids
to be a support system, you know?
And I think more dads, particularly young dads
should take advantage of that.
Like create your own like network of people
who are in a similar situation,
or maybe further down the line who can impart a little bit
of advice and open up that channel of communication
so that when it's rough, you can call somebody
and they can say,
well, I went through that and here's what I did.
Or, you know, just don't forget the beautiful part of it
or whatever it is when it's super hard.
I mean, you did it, when Lumi was born,
you said to me something, 'cause he was born in January
or February, 2018.
You said, you did it.
You almost did the exact same, like share the airtime.
You were like, "Wow, good luck, man.
That's gonna be, it's gonna be a lot."
Or so you said something and-
I think I said, there's this idea like,
oh, when you have a second kid,
it's not like you think, well,
I've already done this before.
Like I got it covered, but you don't realize like,
it's not like double the work.
It's like exponential.
It's like sometimes some crazy.
But you did the thing, you did the like, man, good luck.
See you on the other side or see a never like,
it was kind of funny.
And like, realistically,
he was a highlight in the hard part,
but almost hinged right away into this really sweet
that I thought I've thought about it recently
because we just started putting-
I think about that when you hitchhiked
and then carjack the guy with the van, stole the van,
and drove directly here.
Killed the caveman, tried to steal your job.
Did the-
Take the tow truck driver between like finding
the white tiger?
Hey, so you're white tiger?
(Adam laughing)
No, the very warming.
Is there a basket with lotion
in it in the back of that van?
I was the only one, yeah.
Put the lotion in the basket.
Get in the white tiger.
Get in.
No Rich Roll said to me, "Oh man, it's a lot.
Good luck buddy.
See out there.
See you never."
And then he said hinged perfectly into,
"It was just feels like yesterday I was watching my kid
in the sink, and make this shit last."
And like I thought it was really warm.
And so like, I've taken a lot of cues from you
being a chapter or two or 10 ahead of me in life.
But I think it was a really cool moment of like,
and I think that's cool too.
'Cause it does feel good to hear other dads complain like,
fuck this sucks.
There's something that feels good about that.
But I encourage as many men that are listening
to this as possible to then add the optimism
to add that, like but you have to because it's the best
and you did it with the washing and the sink thing.
I thought it was cute, 'cause your kids are teenagers.
Yeah.
I think, just real quick,
I think the way you put the dad stuff right out there
and your stories and how you present yourself to the world
is very inspiring.
And it does allow for you to feel
like you're a whole person, even with a young kid and like,
you know, feeling like it has been good for me.
I've really enjoyed that.
And then be able to talk to you about it also
at the same time it's been great.
You're right.
I mean, I think there are, I was a member of this kind of,
I still sometimes can join anytime I want,
like these Zoom meetings with like,
there's a guy here in LA who runs these groups
for new fathers and you can come in,
he calls it "Donuts with Dads"
and everyone comes in and they talk about things.
And for awhile I was involved in that.
And then I realized, you know,
I'd rather like the margin thing came into it.
And it's like, as much as I like a support group,
I'm not really a support group kind of guy.
And I'm more lone wolf like you
and I wanna get in the water and run.
And if I only have a period of time
to do one of those three things
support group's gonna be out the window.
But I'm also lucky that we can have these kinds of,
I get it more in like quick texts and stuff
than a formal support group.
But I think if you have the time and want to the formal
support group thing is really good because you know,
people really can talk for an extended period
about what they've been dealing with.
And I think a lot of people get a lot outta that.
I just think the idea of young dads spending a lot of time
thinking about like, how can I be a great dad
and having a number of people that they can turn to
to help guide them, it's like a huge thing.
And I feel like, you know, my dad didn't have that,
you know?
I mean, I'm sure he thought like I wanna be a good dad
and you know, did all the things that he was taught in order
to do that.
But I don't think culturally,
it was like a reflex to like for him to call a friend
and say, "Hey, here's a thing that I'm going through
right now, like what would you do?"
There wasn't a whole lot of naval gazing going out there.
Wasn't a lot of that.
There was like, I'm going to work, you know-
Talk to your mother.
Ill be home when I get home.
Yeah. I buy you clothing and shelter.
Yeah.
And it's true.
Like, you know, I have vivid memories of washing Mathis
in this little sink bowl, you know, in our bedroom.
And it does go so quick and now my youngest being 14,
it seems like yesterday and it seems like 100 years ago.
And so I get to live vicariously through your guys'
experience is your experiences with gratitude
that I'm not in it myself, but also missing it.
You know, it's like, I'm so glad I'm not waking up
in the middle of the night to do that.
Right.
But also there's such a sweetness to that time
that's so precious.
And as you know, like you with the amount of videos
that you're making, I'm sure you're taking a bazillion
photos of your kids all the time.
You develop this like ridiculous library of just countless
images of your kids.
Well, you know, fast forward 15-17 years later,
and you know, how on your iPhone,
you get those little popups,
like reminder of like here's a moment, you know?
Right.
Like, and it shows you photos from your library
from the past.
So mine is just this rotation of like images of my kids
from years ago that I forgot that I even had.
That's awesome.
And then it takes me right back 'cause that image
will trigger a memory of an experience.
And it will take me right back there and it's melancholy
because I miss that, there's a sweetness to that time.
My kids are in a different phase of life right now.
And it's beautiful in its own right.
But it's not-
It's less cute.
It's not the innocent, you know,-
Sure-
Or whatever as a parent, you're like, oh, remember that.
Free.
Before the world got to him.
Totally.
Basically before.
Yeah. It's like innocence lost,
which is like an inevitable thing as a parent of watching
the world start to creep in to, in a formative way
into who these people become.
Right, yeah.
I have a very cynical friend named Laura
and she's had her second kid and she said to me,
she would be one to just do the whole,
like doesn't this suck.
And she would like, kind of like do only do that side of it.
And she said to me recently,
and it's something I think a lot about,
because it's likely their last kid,
she talks about like every diaper or every bottle
or every sleepless night be one of their last in that phase.
So everyone will give advice that everything's just a phase.
But when she kind of nailed down on the exact nature of it,
of like every scraped knee,
when once the training wheels come off,
they're not going back on.
Like, it was a really like nice warming, poetic thing
from someone who was usually kind of Oscar the Grouch.
And it was like, and it's something that I think about it
like almost every day, which is like,
how many more times are you dancing with your kid
in your arms, over the oatmeal, a 100.
Right.
Not, not 700.
You know, is it 50?
Is it 20?
And so when you start to frame it up,
like we're leaving the oatmeal dance session
in 20 more dances.
It's like, well, those are pretty fucking awesome.
You know, those are even more amazing.
And you're not that you're a guy that complaints
actually to me about any of this stuff,
but that helps me frame up.
I try to just stuff it all down-
And then you,-
I just cram it.
The pressure in your head is just so great.
But anyway, I thought that was a nice way of thinking
beyond just the phases, which is a hard thing to grasp like
each little-
That's good.
I think that's about like,
that's something Jesse Itzler talks about all the time.
He did it in the context of like how many more times
are you gonna visit your parents, right.
Right, exactly.
But you can just flip it and put it in the rear view
with respect to how you deal with your kids
and understand that.
Especially when they're young, like those phases come quick
and then they pass and then you're in a new phase.
So how present and mindful can you be,
well, you're in that moment with the understanding,
like this is very, very transient and temporary
and to just appreciate it?
And I think it goes to this idea, like as dads,
you wanna create these epic moments for your kids.
Like, and my mind will veer towards like,
we'll go on this vacation
or I'll take them to this crazy place.
And we're gonna do this adventure,
but there are no, like, it's not,
it's like this idea of quality time.
Every moment presents the opportunity for quality time.
It's the quality of yourself that you bring to the daily
experiences, whether it's making oatmeal
or walking around the neighborhood at night
because your kid won't fall asleep.
And as somebody who's, you know, way further down the line.
When I think back on all the experiences
that I've had with my kids,
particularly when they were young,
it is those innocent little moments.
It's not the grand big gestures.
It's those tiny little things.
I love that.
No such thing as quality time that you have down here,
I'm looking at the doc.
That's a great observation from 10,000 feet
that you kept with you, you know?
I mean, cause you probably use that still.
Still now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Because they're older and then the phase
is kind of lasts a little bit longer and you know,
the kind of bumps along the road are a little bit more
dramatic, you know, as you get into the teenage years
and all of that.
But to remember like, oh, this is just another phase too.
Like, how can I show up?
And rather than resist it, just be present with it.
Presence over,-
No matter how busy you are, like you put the phone aside.
No matter how tired you are when your kid is like,
"Hey, can we go do this thing?
Can I can come and look at like the thing I drew
or whatever?"
Like the answer's always, yes.
It doesn't matter how you feel, how tired you are,
how busy you are, what phone call you're on,
what email you have to send.
Like you just say yes, no matter what.
That's so cool.
I forced like a very like iconic dad moment where-
You forced it?
I forced it.
I was like, you know what?
The kid's three, it's time he goes to a baseball game.
Like, I don't know anything about pro baseball.
We're living in Minneapolis.
I was like, we'll go see the Twins,
get the cheapest tickets.
That's also right.
That's good.
Great dad.
$18, did the top stop thing or get the kid in the shirt,
catch a fly ball, something.
And it's exactly like, he just said, it was like,
I was creating this thing.
That's more about it's about-
It's about you and expectations.
And then we ended up, well, a couple of things.
Number one, he's a liquid nervous little guy
and he's kind of like a very emotional little boy.
And he kept saying,
you can barely see the field.
You can't see the ball when the pitcher we're so far away.
And he goes, "is the ball going to hit us as the ball?"
We are the cheapest.
We are double balcony.
No one's ever hit a ball up.
The game hasn't started.
They're warming up.
I can't believe it's a little eyes can see the pitchers
mountain worst cheapest tickets.
The first hit, I just promise him.
We're not gonna see a baseball.
We're so safe.
First pitch of the game.
It's a home run.
And it comes up to our section and it almost hit us.
And it was so crazy.
It was so crazy and he got scared.
He was like, "Let's get outta here."
I was like, "Let's get out of here."
We got out of there.
And the quality time, the actual presence,
fuck the baseball game.
We left and just went outside and like kind of watched
traffic and watch the train.
And it was like, that was the day.
It was a day about trains and we happen to be wearing
baseball stuff, right.
So I dial into that small moments piece of giving yourself.
It's like so smart because if they're not attached
to the baseball game.
Little boys are Sean Penn and "Sweet and Lowdown."
They just wanna watch trains and shoot the rats.
Totally. Yeah, totally.
So anyway, it was a great day,
but not because of my idea or efforts or tickets
or any of that, we just-
Question is Skolnick, if Zuma doesn't like baseball,
what are you gonna do?
The other question is if Zuma doesn't like going
in the ocean, what am I gonna do?
I mean, nothing.
You know, like it's not my-
That's the thing.
I think I'm pretty good.
My dad is also like that.
My dad met each kid where they were at really well.
He loved playing sports with me,
but he liked doing the train set with my brother.
And he like, you know,
and for me, I think I come up with that.
Like, I don't have fixed ideas of what it is to be a guy
or anything in this world.
Like, I feel like my dad always had that too.
Like, not that he's like over evolved
in that kind of modern ways we think of it,
but like he didn't have fixed expectations for anybody.
And I think that's good.
That means that there's less pressure
and I don't have fixed expectations about,
but that's because I think I cultivate that in my life.
I read the doubt its shame all the time.
And like, I am very Taoist in that expectations
are not my friend.
And so I try to not have them really.
And, and so with him, you know,
that's blessing of being an older dad too.
You know that there's nothing I'm trying to work out.
You know, guys, can I be real?
You're not giving him a speech about what it means
to be a Skolnick.
A few short years ago.
I thought I was sterile.
Turns out I'm virile, who knew.
Good news.
That's the backstory.
(Adam laughing)
I'm an older dad.
I'm like late 40s.
It was not something that was on the calendar.
It was something that came to us and, you know,
we accept life,
but it's not something we ever expected or tried for.
So I think that I keep that in mind.
I take that with me going forward.
But you know, at the same time you could look at it
the other way.
Like all these successful kids had these people,
especially in sports, had these people driving them,
you know, and that doesn't seem to be part of my DNA,
but yeah-
Me neither.
Yeah.
Even as much as I love sports,
in Minnesota, we tried to teach our kid how to skate.
We got them a hockey helmet, so it wouldn't bust his face.
We tried to teach him how to skate last winter.
He mostly kind of, not really didn't get it right.
He fell a lot and he's fine with falling.
But I remember a bunch of dads looking at how big I am
and then looking at that kid, hockey country and saying,
"So what month was he born?
What high school will he go to?"
Right.
And as much as sport has changed my life and been a huge
part of who I am, training, finish, run, whatever.
Like I actually go the other way.
And I throw those Minnesota dads a curve ball.
I'm like, "Yeah, we're thinking theater.
We're thinking dance."
You know, and they just do not know what to do
with that answer.
He loves his ballet.
(Rich laughing)
You do that for a rise though.
(indistinct chattering)
I'm gonna jack this dude up-
We would support whatever is the interest.
And I think the parents that are really hoping
the kid follows in the footsteps are very likely to be-
But some works.
Some it works.
Sometimes.
It can but more often than not,
like it's not rigged that way.
Like in my experience, your kids are become your teachers
because they are, you know,
developing in ways you didn't expect
or whatever pattern you wanted to like impose upon them
becomes, you know, unworkable.
And so you have to become fluid and flexible and figure out,
you know, what they're inspired by
and where their interests lie.
And, you know, just try to fill that gap.
You know, I remember when Tyler and Trapper were like six,
like Trapper was always like banging his hand.
And like, I remember when Julia was like,
"Come on, we're going to Guitar Center"
and said, "Sit behind these drums,"
and just like watched him.
And I was like, "oh, he's a drummer."
So cool.
And you know what he does now?
He's a drummer.
Right.
You know, got him a drum set.
I think he was five or six at the time.
Same thing with Tyler, with guitar.
I mean, Mathis was just a hellion, like running around,
just throwing stuff all over the place.
So Julie, let her paint on all the walls just said,
go for it, here's paint.
Like, do whatever you want.
Like the, I mean, we had this like this modern,
she's like, I don't care.
I want a house of life rather than, you know,
a prestige-
I like that too.
And now, and you know, we'd literally go and stretch
giant canvases for her also and put them outside
and just let her, like, you know,
Math is two years old, like naked,
like throwing paint at these canvases.
And now she's applying to art school.
So you never know.
And I think it about-
Julie know,
(indistinct chattering)
Julie is advising-
Julie is the one he should be sitting here.
(Adam laughing)
This was all Julie.
But the idea of like, oh, I see a little thing here.
Like, how can I go move in and like, fill that-
But the one thing, and this is a dad question for you,
not the two of us in the early stages is like,
but when do you know that you've tried something
like, if a kid this week is interested in the violin
and next week is interested in gymnastics,
do you just press go on everything?
Or is there a point where you say,
no, we're gonna do a second week of violin.
We're gonna try this for a third week.
I think that's a delicate dance.
Right.
Yeah. It's really hard to figure out what that is.
You should read David Epstein's book "Range" though,
'cause it's kind of all about that.
It's really a study, a look at like all of these crazy
high performers who've become super successful
in every kind of field from science to athletics.
And it destroys that notion of like
the Todd Marinovich is and the Tiger Woods
who just like are maniacs from little kids
and just go all in on one thing.
Most of the people who are wildly successful
in their chosen field, tried a million different things
for a very long time and were kind of late bloomers
to the thing that finally becomes their thing.
So I think the balance of the effort should be in exposing
a young people to as many things as possible.
And when they wanna pull out,
sometimes you gotta hit the brakes and say,
well, you said you would do like,
make a commitment ahead of time.
We're gonna do this for six months or a month
or whatever it is, hold them to that to some regard,
because it's important for them to learn like, oh,
you made a commitment.
You have to show up, even when you don't feel like it.
But at some point it's like, okay,
this is not gonna be their thing.
They wanna go do over here, that's fine.
And not, I think, you know, like the generation before us
or my parents' generation, it's like,
no, this is what you're doing.
You play baseball.
Yeah. And didn't let us, or, you know,
pull out or try as many things as maybe we should.
And maybe now we do too much of the latter.
So there's some sweet spot in the middle there.
I think the idea of, how long, like,
what's the shortest period that you can try something, but,
you know, yeah.
Mathis did hockey for a while and then she's like,
"I'm done."
Yeah.
Okay.
Like, as soon as he shows up with goggles
and instead of a mask, and I be like Skolnick
we're mask people.
Right.
We wear the mask.
If you're-
Not.
If Zuma shows up with swim goggle and says,
"I like goggles."
Did uncle Rich talk to you?
(Rich laughing)
I like normal goggles Dad.
I don't wanna be one of those mask dorks,
like you and your friends.
Dad you're the only guy you're literally the only guy
in the ocean.
(all laughing)
My dad's the mask dad.
Yeah, why do your dad wear that weird mask bro?
And when he dropped me off in the car at school,
you're wearing it.
Yeah. You don't have to wear it when you drop me off
at school.
PTO meetings.
(all laughing)
A lot of people don't realize it,
but one of my dad idols is,
I'm screwing up the.
(Adam laughing)
Nice.
It's so important to us that, do you remember who it is?
"Tenenbaums."
Got it.
"Royal Tenenbaums?"
"Royal Tenenbaum" is my dad.
Model father.
Yeah, got it.
Yeah.
Got it.
How about, Logan Roy in "Succession."
Another great guy, other nice fellow.
He's a nice fellow.
He wrote "Dads" who are some hero dads.
Other than Royal and Logan.
Logan.
Rupert.
(Adam laughing)
Rupert Murdoch.
Who do you look to Brogan?
Brogan.
I don't know man.
There's a couple in San Diego.
I will not name drop, but they have five kids
and they're all seemingly within the same year.
Like they're all like the same age pretty much.
And they just live and not just like the IG,
not just the Instagram, like posting the smiley pictures,
they really just live an optimistic life.
So that idea of like, when your baby's like a lot
in a certain day, you do that thing where you're like,
well, it's not twins, right?
I think of them all the time.
It's just like, they're soaking it up.
And this dad seems to be on fire
with just like true optimism, five kids.
So that to me is like,
there's something there just about perspective
or patients or all of the above.
Talk about-
One of the things, you know,-
You could have decade there, you know.
You know, we all have that experience
of going on Instagram and there are people
who are living more, you know, interesting lives
or more aspirational lives and you feel like,
ah, what am I doing?
Or you feel less than the thing that really gets me though,
is dads being amazing dads on Instagram that make me feel
insecure about, my daddying abilities,
or I'm like, yeah, I really wasn't as good
as I could have been when they were younger.
When I see dads being incredible,
that like gets me every time.
Like scout the dog on bluey 'cause that's my-
Or just some, you know,
there's these videos that circulate around
and like it's some dad doing something amazing
with their young kid.
Right. I know, but they're putting it on an Instagram.
So it's kind of phony.
I call BS on that.
Yeah.
But sometimes it's captured by someone else
and they put it on.
I prefer to Brogan like skateboarding.
And I think the reason I bring that up is if I feel
that way, I'm sure there's a lot of other dads
who feel that way.
And I think it's the degree of like daddying difficulty
is intimidating because you're expected to be the provider.
You're also, you know, sort of supposed to be the strong guy
who kind of lays down the boundary and the law,
but you also have to be heartfelt and venerable,
emotionally available, and-
But all of those things are immutable now-
You are now expected to go to every school function.
Like there was somebody who tweeted.
It was a really funny tweet.
It's like, I think it was,
I can't remember who it was, maybe Patent Oswald's brother.
He was like, "I'm retiring from my career
to commit myself full time to reading my kids' school email.
Like, I can tell you when your kids get older
and they're like, I literally get, maybe I get at least two,
maybe three to five emails a day from each of the schools
that my kids go to.
Like, I get like at least 10 emails a day-
That's too communication.
I can't like, will you be this?
Do you wanna be on the advisory committee?
Don't forget about the bake sale.
And then this thing is happening.
And I was like, it's unbelievable.
And then as a dad, now, you're not Don Draper.
Like you gotta show up for all this stuff.
And it's like two o'clock on a Tuesday.
Totally.
And I'm self-employed for the, you know,
so I have flexibility over my schedule, but like,
what about the guy who does go to an office every day
and is expected to work from, I mean,
how are you feeling when, look, I can't leave my job.
I can't go to anything.
Yeah.
Yeah. The guy who can't go to any of that, I mean-
That's why Don Draper became Don Draper because he started
getting those emails and he just was like,
"I'm gonna go to the way."
(Adam laughing)
He created zero expectation that he will ever show up
for anything.
He literally left his daughter's sixth birthday party.
But then also, I know amazing human beings
who were raised by fathers like that.
Yeah. We get that.
We get the emails Lumi's in preschool.
But I think we probably get three to five a day
from preschool.
Now they're not informational.
It's just him doing finger paintings.
It's super cute, but I get it.
At some point.
Yeah. It's going that way.
I also think there's room for every Instagram dad
that's doing like some really cute dance moment thing,
which is good.
I think that exposes like a good role and it's good to see.
It's good modeling.
I also think it's okay to admit some of the mess ups,
you know, you said something about skateboarding.
When we moved to Minneapolis,
I put my kid in a helmet and I missed the boardwalk
in California.
So I put him on the front of a skateboard,
something I've never done before.
He was one and a half years old.
Right.
And we went out and it was like, I mean,
we definitely in the same moment,
went off a crack in the sidewalk and just both went down
really, really hard and used the shit out of our helmets.
Right, kid is fine.
I was fine, no crying.
And I looked over and a neighbor saw me and she goes like,
she was very nice.
She goes, "Are you guys okay?"
I was like, "Yeah."
And the kid actually is fine.
And I just remember being like that looked outrageously
terrible.
And I think there's something that okay.
About admitting mistakes and fuck ups,
because there was a good intention.
Maybe I was trying to adventure more than I was ready for,
but it's like, that's can be funny.
That can be daddying.
And I think that tell mom.
(Adam laughing)
And don't tell mom that vibe, right?
We tried something I screwed up.
We're gonna keep a secret.
(Adam laughing)
That's a good practice as a model.
There's a crack in your helmet.
We're going shopping.
We're go shopping for a new helmet.
But mom will find out.
Yeah, there was no concussion, I think.
But anyway, like the idea of like trading notes
on things that didn't work and things that did work,
like, no, one's really getting an A plus on this thing.
We're just kind of stumbling through it, so.
And you know what,
I'm gonna end this by a shout out to the moms,
because I know, I mean, obviously I don't know Goldie,
but obviously we know Julie's incredible wisdom,
intuition and abilities and leadership qualities
have been really helpful.
And, and like April, listen, man.
The reason I can be kind of more chill in my role
is because I mean, (Adam laughing) 85% of the work
is being taken off my plate, so.
Yeah. And Brogan is here in Los Angeles.
Goldie is at home right now.
(Adam laughing)
I'm here.
With a newborn and.
(Adam laughing)
At the table.
Well, I told you this on the phone.
You're like, "I'm gonna go to,
Hey babe, I know I got like a brand new newborn,
but like, but Roll-On is calling
and I gotta break bread with Skolnick."
Yeah. Skolnick and I got to like squash the beef
plus there's these ads I gotta read, it makes no sense.
(Rich laughing)
That I told you this.
I told you this because we FaceTimed with Adam Skolnick.
So she's a new fan of his, but she's a fan of yours.
And she press go on the idea because she does,
she spent a lot of time with you guys on walks,
getting ready to deliver this baby.
And so it was cool.
So shout out to all the moms that make the daddying space
possible to make any margins possible.
And at the same time, you know,
keep telling positive dads stories, man.
I think if there's another little kernel in there,
it's that it's important to make sure that within
the very limited spectrum of time that you have,
that you do carve out a little bit of time to nourish
yourself and whatever that is.
So for you right now, it's this dramatic, you know,
sort of stroke of like coming out here, but on some level,
like you're being nourished by this experience,
this is very Brogan for you to be here.
Goldie knows like, oh, I need to let Brogan do this
because when he comes back, he'll be a better,
a more present dad.
That's an extreme example of something
I think you could practice on the daily, whether it's Adam,
you getting the opportunity to go jump in the ocean
a couple of times a week or whatever it is like,
you gotta be able to hold on to that and not become
completely consumed by the experience.
Because if you do, then you'll start to get resentful.
And that compounded by the fatigue
and the sleep deprivation,
all of that is going to get expressed in an unhealthy way.
And fitness is key, you know,
like you can not let go of the fitness strand.
In my opinion, for me it's been very key
because being again, I keep saying this,
but it is true an older dad.
And so like, I'm looking at chasing down this kid
who mother's very athletic and I need to be able to,
you know, be present.
So I look at it as part of my job as a dad to stay fit.
And I think it's true.
And it also helps you process the stress
and all the sleeplessness and all the other kind
of nasty thoughts that want to creep into your head.
So as we all know, being people who care about exercise
and love doing it, just because it's fun.
That is also as we know a very important by-product.
So I think, yes, the first month, take your time,
whatever, but like find it,
you gotta find the margin for that.
And make sure that you're providing that opportunity
for your partner.
Yep.
Right. So we were joking Brogan,
it's your birthday next week.
You're like, well, you know, -
Its canceled.
Yeah, it's canceled because you're here, right?
So what are you gonna do?
Go back and like, so I said,
what you should ask for your birthday is the opportunity
to provide Goldie with like a spa day.
You know?
Like you can't, I mean, this is like,
oh, what are the dads need?
It's like, well, you know,
any woman who's a mom who's listening to this
is gonna be like, are you fucking kidding me?
She's already flipped us off, six times.
No, for sure.
(Adam laughing)
For sure.
The amount of moms have fallen off drastically
because the episode continues on all there is no more moms
left at this point of the podcast, they're gone.
No. Yeah.
I mean, providing your partner with the space.
I mean, that is key and Goldie super active.
And so to get her 30 minute walk or a 30 minute run,
she's about to get cleared pretty soon to work out again,
hopefully and all those things, so.
Yeah.
Spa day for my birthday.
That they're being nourished in the manner
in which they deserve, I think is key.
Yeah. And you know,
April's gonna run that Malibu Half marathon is her idea
that I'm just tagging along and she's gonna break two hours
and I'm gonna get there when I get there.
Totally.
(Adam laughing)
Yeah. You might not see that.
Yeah. There'll be parking.
She'll be gone after like the three mile.
You gotta earn your spot the far club, right?
Yeah. I'm in the far behind the club far.
I'll be the head of the far behind.
Far behind.
Yeah.
I like it, it's cool.
It's cool. Right.
I think we've put a bow on it.
Final thought, keep the phone away from them as long
as possible.
Yeah. When you're checking Instagram
while they're playing, make sure that they can't see it.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. So like, yeah.
So when my Zuma is sleeping,-
You think they can't see it, but they know,
they know, its not you say, the most important thing is,
is not what you say, it's how you behave.
It's what you're doing.
Yep.
Yeah. And that's how they're modeling their behavior.
I thought were ending on a happy note.
(Adam laughing)
That's heavy rich.
Sheesh.
Whoa.
Didn't think about that one.
Bros, sheesh.
Brogan, beef squash my friend.
Love you man.
Yeah.
I think you're incredible.
And yeah, and I'm a fan.
I'm a fan of the Roll-On and it got me back into
the Rich Roll podcast.
And you know, I feel about you love letters for days.
Yeah man, love-
You're a genuinely hilarious-
I'm glad I was able to curate the experience of us all
being together.
You do this, you do this out in the world.
You're the one who got on a plane and came here.
You do this in the world.
This is what you are.
And you do it at the table.
Look at this.
What does your Brogan do?
What does this Roll-On do?
It's good.
That's good.
I'll have to think about that.
Alright, love you guys.
We're gonna take another quick break.
Now we're gonna be back with my conversation
with ultra runner Robbie Ballenger.
You know him as the guy who ran across America,
he broke the record for most Central Park loops in 24 hours,
ran 100 miles and his most recent accomplishment
doing this Colorado Crush insanity,
which entailed an entire summer of killing
Colorado Peaks fourteeners he traversed the Colorado Trail.
He completed Leadville, all kinds of stuff.
So this conversation again was recorded live
at the Legendary Explorers Club in New York City
as part of my Ten Thousand FAR capsule
launch party celebration.
It's coming right up.
Love you guys.
But is he a dad?
No, he's not a dad.
So. That's pretty easy for a non-dad.
I mean, that's pretty simple.
I was gonna do.
So could be dismissive,
to anybody who does anything amazing
because they don't have kids.
If I had the hours,
how many laps I do around Central Park.
Sounds like big margins.
Yeah.
Well, if I didn't use margins on that guy,
I could break that record.
(Adam laughing)
(indistinct chattering)
(Brogan speaking foreign language)
(audience clapping)
How cool is this?
Thank you everybody for coming out.
Like I said before, the run,
this is a celebration of a creative collaboration
with Ten Thousand.
I'm so proud of the kit.
How do you like the kit Robbie?
It's amazing.
You have to say that right?
(Rich laughing)
Like right there on the spot.
I am really proud of it.
It was really amazing to collaborate with such a talented
group of people.
I've never worked with a company that was more responsive
to athlete feedback.
The number of samples that I continue to get in the mail
over the course of a year was insane.
I couldn't believe how immersive it was as an experience
and it was really creatively fulfilling.
So I just wanna thank everybody at Ten Thousand,
Keith of course, Dominic, Travis, Brian,
everybody who collaborated on what we're here to celebrate
today, so thank you guys.
I'm really proud to be here.
(audience clapping)
I have the distinct honor of hosting a conversation
with my friend Robbie here, Robbie Ballenger.
Many of you probably know Robbie already.
He's distinguished as a extraordinary athlete
and ambassador of running.
Not only as he run across the United States,
he recently broke the 24 hour Central Park loop record.
Did I say that right?
I don't know what it's called exactly.
Central Park loop challenge.
Yeah. And he ran how many miles in Central Park?
Oh, it's actually, it's the hours it's open.
So it's from 6:00 AM until midnight is the time
you have to run, which is 19 hours.
I finished in 18 hours and seven minutes with 16 loops.
So it was 98 miles in some change.
Right. But then you, you made sure you tagged on
a few miles.
Yeah.
(indistinct chattering)
Like what's the point of getting that far
and not going to 100.
(all laughing)
Three digits always looks better that two.
So, 98.6 miles in 17-
18 hours and seven minutes.
So most of you, many of you I'm sure
have run the full, is it 6.2,
the full Central Park loop, right?
Raise your hand if you've done that loop.
How many of you can imagine running that for 98.6 miles?
Yeah. Harlem hill gets real big.
(all laughing)
I've had the privilege of watching Robbie
evolve as a runner.
I met him on the very first day of his attempt to cross
the country by foot.
It was like, who's this guy didn't really know
that much about him.
We ran for a couple of miles and then he went on his way
and I thought, I don't know if I'll ever see that guy again
or whether he's gonna make it or not.
(audience laughing)
And I've watched this individual continue to double down,
iterate and improve as an athlete.
And you've really matured into this incredible ambassador
of the sport.
So I just wanted to credit you for that.
And it's been so great to watch you take on and tackle
these challenges, I'm like catch a breath, you know,
take a break for a minute,
but let's talk about what you did this past summer,
the Colorado Crush.
So maybe explain to people what you spent
most of your entire summer doing.
Yeah. So the Colorado Crush consisted
of three parts.
It started with the Leadville trail series.
So Leadville town in Colorado at 10,000 feet,
it's the highest incorporated town in Colorado.
They have a rate series in June.
There is a marathon,
July, a 50 miler in August 100.
So I did all of those between the marathon and the 50 miler.
I ran the Colorado Trail.
So 485 miles, I did that in 11 days.
And then between the 50 miler and the 100,
I summited all 58 peaks over 14,000 feet in Colorado.
So cumulatively, when I got done,
it was just under 1200 miles.
And then the stat that I'm really proud of is it was 308,000
feet of elevation gain.
So that's the equivalent of summiting Everest
from sea to summit 10 and a half times in two months.
(audience laughing)
We are in the explorers club.
I'm like, I don't know where to go with that.
I think what's amazing is that it's easy for somebody
to hear that and think, well,
I can't even connect with that.
Like that's so outrageous that you must just be some freak
of nature, but you're not somebody who's been doing
this for actually all that long.
So maybe catch people up who don't know a little bit
about your backstory, how you got into running,
because this is relatively a recent phenomenon,
this kind of life overhaul that you've been on.
Yeah, I grew up in athletics.
I played team sports, predominantly football,
believe it or not, I was an offensive lineman
(all laughing)
How much did you weigh?
I was not like a big one.
I had fast feet and that kinda carried over,
but probably weighed about,
I think at my heaviest was actually after that in college,
I weighed like 225 from about 175 now,
and then post high school, a little bit of college.
I ended up in the restaurant industry for many years,
ending with owning being part owner
in some Neapolitan pizzerias in Austin, Texas.
And in that time I was just like living that restaurant
lifestyle work hard party real hard.
And it wasn't really adding up to me being the leader
I wanted to be for these restaurants
and on the encouragement of my fiance, Shelley,
she invited me on a two and a half mile run and that was it.
Like it changed my life.
And it's just been since then,
like two and a half miles turned into a half marathon,
two months later, a marathon the next year, 50 miler.
And then I left the restaurant and I didn't know
what I wanted to do next.
And some things kind of coral less.
And I decided I was going to run across
the United States and I would do it to create conversations
about better food choices and promote the efficacy
of a plant-based diet.
And so that was where this, like,
I kind of made my name in the running scene.
And then it's just been since then a couple of more big
efforts and refining what matters to me about running
and what are the things I need to be the best runner I can.
Mm-mmh.
So when you're, and this gets into kind of the theme
or the ethos of what today is all about,
like when you're running across America
or you're running Leadville or in the midst
of one of these unbelievable challenges,
like what is going on in your mind?
Like, what is your brain doing and how are you, you know,
staying on track and not letting you know,
kind of the dark demons get the best of you.
Yeah. I mean, for me,
like that's the problem with these things.
One leads to the next 'cause where I dream up,
the next challenge is usually on the one before it,
but while I'm out there, I mean, it's just,
running is where I go to better understand myself,
to just hash through all the parts of me that need work on.
And like, I think you can't really work on something
until you can identify it.
And on runs is where identify things.
It's like, okay, this is a part of me.
This is why I do this thing I do.
And now let me sift through what that is,
and what, what it means to me.
And like this summer I've been on this long journey
of my father died when I was really, really young.
I realized kind of through the Transcon run
that a lot of what I was doing was trying to define
what it means to be a man.
And then this summer starting with the Central Park
loop challenge, which I did here in New York,
right before that my uncle died, my dad's brother.
And that brought all that back to the surface.
And so from there it was sifting through this
of just like, what does this mean?
And I think what I came to through the Colorado Trail,
especially part of the summers effort
is I came to peace with that and I realized
that I'm no longer looking for what it means.
I'm just expressing it.
I'm expressing my version of what it means to be a man.
So that was like the big thing that came out of this summer,
but it's always something new and it's always a place for me
to yeah, just figure those things out
and then dream about the next thing.
Yeah. I feel like there's a fine line between
the indulgence of running at the ultra level,
like the way that you engage with it on the one hand,
it can be lever for ordinary self improvement,
self understanding, (indistinct chattering)
for unlocking hidden potential coming the best version
of yourself.
But the flip side, it can literally use running to run away
from those very things, those demons that you're trying
to hide from.
And I see both versions of that.
So I'm curious whether you've come up against that.
Like at some point, if you're doing so many challenges,
the question has to be asked like,
are you running away from something or are you running
towards something?
So how do you kind of think about that?
And get on with that?
I mean, thus far, just all the markers say
that it's going in the right direction,
I'm running towards something.
You're in a healthy relationship still.
Yeah. I've still got my fiance and yeah.
I mean, thus far it's, it's redefining me as a person
in a way that seems all positive.
I understand that there's that other side of it,
my mom will ask me that one.
She's like, "Is this just an addiction?"
And I was like, "It's better than the old ones."
Like, you know,
(audience laughing)
Yeah. My friend Mishika said to me.
'Cause he gets asked that same question,
the way he answers it is, "the drink or the drug was always
the easy choice putting on the running shoes
is the hard choice."
Absolutely.
And it builds resilience in the rest of your life.
You know, like just the getting out on the run.
I live in Denver, Colorado.
And like, as I was preparing
for the Central Park loop challenge,
like a big thing I was doing was getting out
and running when it was really cold.
And a lot of that was just about gaining that,
get up and go muscle, you know, just like really,
'cause I'm gonna do a loop around Central Park.
I'm gonna stop. I'm gonna see my, my family, my friends,
I got to get back out there.
And so just building that resiliency.
Yeah. So thus far for me,
I feel like running has been very positive.
Yeah. So what does Free Association Run
mean to you?
Robbie Balenger?
I think like, to me, like when I think of that,
I think a lot about Knox Robinson's here, right?
And he's mentioned,
I think it was him that said like, "Running his rebellion."
I think running is also selfish,
but I don't think selfish has to be a bad word.
Like it's a place where you get to commune with yourself.
And this summer, what I realized being in the mountains
compared to running on the side of the road is like,
there's this world that we live in and all the technology
and everything, it has all these great things,
but it also can really beat you down.
And like when I got out on the trail,
I realized none of that was there even to more of an extent
than I normally do.
But in that, that running's kind of selfish.
We just to get to disassociate with all of these things
that just can kind of drive us nuts in a way,
even when we don't know it, and you get to be centered
with yourself and you get to learn from yourself,
the most growth comes internally.
And again, it's back to that idea of just sifting through
who I am, the things I wanna do.
And often you, because you're running,
there's no barriers to where your thought goes.
Like often I come home with an idea
and I have to reign it in.
I'm like, that was great.
But like, let's be realistic here.
(Robbie laughing)
One of the problems that I have
is I'll have those sparks of inspiration
when I'm out running and I don't wanna stop
and like type them into a note or like record a voice, like,
is that interrupts the thing?
But if I don't do that, then they become very elusive
and they might like I'll forget them quickly.
So it's always a challenge to figure out how to like capture
the best of what might percolate up during a run
versus interrupting that flow.
How do you deal with that?
I think I wait until it happens
a couple of times, you know, I run a lot.
So it's like when those ideas come and pop into my head
a couple of times on a run and then they resonate
and I remember them, I'm sure there's a lot of missed,
but also sometimes stop and write them down.
Like I'm not a very fast runner.
I just go really far.
And in that, like running should be enjoyable.
So when I'm out on a run,
I'm not usually worried about splits.
I'll take that time to just like calm down,
write it down and keep going.
But I wouldn't say often more.
It's just those things that come up often.
I mean, they need to be paid attention to.
Right. If you follow Robbie on Instagram,
he always shares photos that he takes during his run.
So I know that you're at least stopping a little bit
to like enjoy the experience.
And I was joking after the run that we just had,
the intention for the run was for it to be silent for us
to have that free association experience,
to kind of pay attention to the breath, to, you know,
get into that higher state of consciousness where creativity
can percolate up and we can associate disparate ideas
and kind of have that spark of inspiration.
But instead there was a lot of talk nonetheless,
and I was as guilty of that as anyone else.
And it made me think like, you know, the idea was like,
come back and share what that experience was about
or what came up for you.
And for me it was a couple of things.
One like extreme gratitude to just be in New York City
in the fall and run like what an extraordinary privilege
it is to run a New York City
and to be part of this community.
Like I do a lot of my running alone.
I live in a pretty remote place
and I'm just out trail running by myself.
And it reminded me how important community is,
and how good that felt to be with a group
of like-minded people,
and running for me, and my relationship with it is,
is this combination of that's so low experience
where you can go deep on yourself
and really kind of be in that active meditation space
that is so healthy and kind of healing for me.
And then on the flip side of that,
to have the community experience and you,
as somebody who goes really long, I mean,
I wanna talk about the Colorado Crush and that experience
in a little bit more detail.
But one of the things that I think was notable
about it was this combination of these solo expeditions,
but then you would pop in on these races
and have kind of that communal like suck or, you know,
to get fed by, you know, your fellow community runners.
Yeah, absolutely.
It was a place to come in and commune with others.
Absolutely. Like the effort of the Colorado Crush
was those three efforts.
And they all kind of ended up being meaning something
different for me individually.
And it was that like the races were communal,
it was a place to celebrate running
with all these other people in this beautiful town
of Leadville.
And then the Colorado Trail was very introspective.
It was just me on the trail, long swaths of time
while I was by myself, like there was one day I was out,
it was 56 miles and it took me 19 and a half hours.
And I didn't have any crew through all of that.
So like a lot of time to just commune with myself.
And then the fourteeners were just this immense amount
of gratitude.
Like when you get to wake up every day and see sunrise
on the top of a mountain, like, you're just like,
I'm so lucky.
Like it was just so much gratitude for it.
So each of them kind of had their own specific meaning
in there.
So you were driving around in this van, right?
It had your name on it.
Do you still have the van?
Absolutely.
Did you drive the van here?
No, no, no, no.
I was hoping you'd have, when I showed up here,
it would be parked up front.
Yeah, right.
No, I drove enough this summer,
Colorado, you can drive a lot in that state if you want to,
like, I've seen every inch of it, so.
Let's talk a little bit
about the run across America.
I mean, we did a on that, where we went into it at length,
but a lot of people here may not have heard that.
Maybe just share a few.
Well, first of all,
explain the process of how you did that.
How many miles you were running every day
and then maybe share a couple highlights and low points
and, you know, tackling that challenge.
Yeah. So it was 3,175 miles.
I did it in 75 days.
So from Huntington Beach, just south of Los Angeles
to Central Park, it was me really venturing
into this big ultra endurance efforts and looking back,
like I probably bit off a tiny bit more than I could chew.
I got it done, but I pushed my mind,
my body everyday to the limit.
And it was done to again about being plant-based
and that was new to me.
So it was something I really wanted to talk to others about.
And I wanted to prove to myself
that it was the right choice.
And I proved to myself that it was,
it's definitely what works for me.
Along the way, there were lots of highs and lows
the first month, much harder than the rest of it.
Well, all of it was really hard,
but it got a little bit easier after a month,
day 19, I really probably came to my darkest place
and ended up having to take a day off.
I had like really bad tendonitis in my leg.
And in that day, though, in retrospect,
a lot of growth came out of it.
It was the one moment where I wasn't sure
if I'd be able to continue.
And in that you kind of give yourself up to do the energy
of the world, a higher power, whatever it might be.
And that was really important for me.
Like somebody that just grips tightly to control,
letting that go and realizing that it was too big for me
to just like force it the whole time
and having to go with the flow,
put one foot in front of the other
and yeah, take it day by day.
So that was definitely like low,
but also one of the highest points.
The Navajo Nation in general
is just a really beautiful place.
I ran through that for like eight days,
a special, special place that I truly loved.
Yeah. It was just great.
Appalachians will absolutely crush your soul though.
Like Pennsylvania really hard, like, yeah.
(audience laughing)
He's so casual and cavalier about this stuff.
Like it's no big deal.
Like it's crazy what you've done.
The thing that really stands out for me about you
and kind of how you approach your running
and your athleticism is that there's this service piece
to it in that when you're not in the midst of tackling
your own challenge, you pop in on these other people's
challenges and help them along.
So you were a big part of Hellah Sidibe's
run across America, the other summer he also ended up
here in New York City and would've been here today,
but he's out of town, I guess.
And then also you were just in the UK helping out
some other guys, on some other crazy challenge.
And I just like the idea that you give yourself over,
like, there's a humility to that.
I think that you have this practice of showing up in service
to other people who are trying to do things similar
to what you've done.
So talk a little bit about how that plays into how you think
of yourself as an athlete and a man,
because this whole idea of like how to be a man
is a big part for you.
Yeah. With both of those guys, like,
I think the, like why we're the three of us,
I'm dear friends with both of them now,
but it all came from a place of meeting them both in,
through our meeting,
understanding that they wanted their challenge
as bad as I wanted mine.
And you need people to help you along the way.
And you know, in mind, like certain people stood up
and took the lead to help me make it happen.
And I saw an opportunity to do that for both of these guys.
And they're just two people too that are just like,
you know, there's those people in life
that just resonate with you.
And like, they're like brothers
and you just know it right away.
And luckily both of them are that for me.
And then, you know, they're both very different people.
I mean, Hellah, if anyone is familiar with Hellah,
I think most people are at this point,
he's becoming an icon.
You just are attracted to him.
He's just, he's just such a positive person.
And I try to be positive,
but the more around Hellah it rubs off.
So I get something out of it too.
And that's a really big deal.
And then William Goodge, who I just helped,
he did a 48 and 30.
He ran 48 marathons in each county in England, in 30 days,
ending with the London marathon where he ran a 306.
48 marathons in 30 days.
Yeah, yeah.
In different places?
Each county.
So we were hopping around.
And with him, it was a little bit different.
When I met him, I went over right after we did our podcasts,
I went over to the UK and he did joggle, John O'Groats
to Land Ends.
And he started at the tip of Scotland
and went to the bottom.
He was not ready.
He bluffed his training.
16 days, he got it done.
It was like 59 miles a day.
But he was on the heels of his mother passing, Mandy.
She died of cancer.
And so like our bond comes through that loss.
Yeah. 'Cause my father died when I was young.
That's a lot to do with why I run.
William definitely runs for Mandy,
and I don't know anybody else in my circle
that that's why we run.
So that's kind of our kinsmanship and he's 10 years younger
than me, and he's like a little brother,
like a bigger little brother, but yeah.
He's yeah, so those are my.
When you were back in the restaurant industry,
could you have imagined this life that you're living now?
Absolutely not.
It wasn't that long ago.
No, it still shocks me.
My birthday was just the other day.
And I posted on Instagram about that.
I was like five years ago.
I never thought I am where I am now.
And what I realized about that that's really exciting
is that means, I don't know where I'm gonna be
in five more years.
And that's really fun to like, know that every day is new.
And if you embrace life and go with the flow and sometimes
force things like life can be really exciting.
Yeah. So there may be people in this room
who are in the earlier stages of trying to figure out
who they wanna be, the trajectory that they're on.
Maybe they're considering some life changes or some pivots.
So talk a little bit about how you figured that out
for yourself and how you got yourself into a state
of mind to make some pretty drastic changes
and incur some risk and kind of blaze this unique path
that you've been on.
Yeah. I mean, everything I do,
I put myself into wholeheartedly like 110% everything.
And with that, like you give yourself fully,
there's a point, there might be a breaking point
where you've given yourself so much that you kind of break.
And that's kind of what happened with me
with the restaurant.
It was almost like there wasn't a choice.
Like it was over.
I had to take a break from that.
And with that, my mom always has told me when I was a kid,
"You can do anything you set your mind to."
And so like getting into, running to this degree,
running across the United States was kind of like,
all right, let me see if that's true.
And, and I did it.
So I like, my thought like,
I've come to this recently is like,
life's gonna throw you shit, no matter what you do,
you're gonna be disappointed.
There's gonna be things obstacles to overcome.
Whether you sit on the couch or you run across the country,
so you might as well do what you wanna do.
Like get out there, put yourself out there
and make that your obstacles.
And then at the end, you'll be where you wanna be
instead of still sitting on the couch.
But yeah, and that's just keep redefining myself
and try new things for the sake of,
we only have one life to live.
Maybe, maybe there's more,
but that's all we know about for sure.
And I think that comes from losing my father
at such a young age.
Like I just wanna embrace every day and make the best
of it because you don't know when it's over.
And that, I think that makes me never be able to like,
ideally sit by and not do what really speaks to me.
I mean, I have my lows.
I've even since running across the U.S.
it hasn't been a direct path to me sitting here with you
right now.
I, at one point, kinda didn't know if I could do it.
I lost like the confidence and I tried something else.
And then it was like, that definitely doesn't work.
Let me get back into this.
So nothing's linear and perfect.
Even as I sit here.
On that point specifically,
talk a little bit about failure
and how you think about failure.
I mean, obviously you can't do anything extraordinary
without incurring the risk of failure and failing time
and time again.
So how do you conceptualize that?
To me, it's just like,
it's all in mindset and we get to choose what we hang on to.
And like, I just choose to celebrate my victories
and take my defeats and throw them to the wind.
Like, what's the point?
We can be constructive if we have the right mindset
and to me, failures are going to happen,
but they're just part of the learning process.
And you're gonna learn something from it,
but you get to decide if you're gonna let it beat you,
or you're just gonna not like beat it, just let it go,
like, get it out of the way and keep going.
I would suspect there's some people
here who maybe have a dream or a big idea
that have something that they want to accomplish
in their life.
And maybe that's an idea that recurs,
when they go out and run and they kind of meditate
and are in that space and they're keep looping back
to this thing that they wanna do,
but they just can't get off the dime.
Like they're paralyzed by that first step
or they're in that state of mind where they feel like
they have to have it all figured out before they can begin.
Or they're just irrational about the level of risk
mitigation that's required before trying something hard.
So maybe we're probably getting near the end
of our time here.
Like I wanna leave people with some kind of tactical
inspiration around the beginning process
of like actualizing a dream.
Well, it all does begin with that first step.
And like, if you're scared to take the first step,
like get past that, take the first, because any big goal,
it's gonna require a lot of little steps to get there,
whether that be running across the United States,
starting a business, whatever it is.
And you got to chop it up into manageable pieces.
When I ran across the United States,
it was in five mile segments, every five miles.
I'd see my crew take on water, take on food.
And that's what I started focusing on.
I couldn't, when I left Huntington Beach,
think about New York, too big, too far,
some days I couldn't think about the end of the day,
but I could think about five miles.
And so it's just about one foot in front of the other.
Those obstacles are gonna come.
You'll get past them and just keep moving.
One foot in front of the other big goals
require a lot of little goals.
What are you up to next?
I'm gonna go home for a minute.
I think Shelly's gonna be happy to have me.
And then I've got a lot of challenges in my head
that are kind of swirling me and Hellah talking about one.
I would like next year to go back over to the UK.
There's a thing called Three Peaks Challenge.
Highest point in Wales, Scotland, and England.
If you traverse them by foot, it's about 500 miles
hit all the top of the peaks.
I'd like to set that or grab the FKC for that.
It's that the thing that Tony Riddle did.
He did it as well, yeah, he did barefoot,
which is funny, Tony.
Like we,-
I mean.
You know, we ran into him on the last day
of William's run.
William was coming south when he did joggle as well.
Tony did, he was going south to north.
We were coming north to south and on William's last day,
it was Tony's first day.
And we met up like on the road, just ran into each other.
And of course, all he did was look at our feet
and I had-
Judgment.-
(Rich laughing)
I had Luna sandals on at the moment.
He's like, "Good shoes."
I was like, but yeah.
So I would like to do that.
I signed up for the Cruel Jewel 100 it's in Georgia.
It's 100 mile race with 34,000 feet of gain.
The 50 miler version of that was my first big ultra.
So it's gonna be kind of like, I grew up in Georgia too.
So it's kind of like a going back to where it all started.
That's kind of the goal of that one.
Cool.
Are we in a place to open it up to questions, right now?
Rich has an amazing podcast.
What are you listening to, or what doing with your mind?
What are you doing over and over again?
Because that's essentially battling that mental, you know,
once you there, 'cause it's a lot to kind of deal with,
you know?
Great question.
Dan must have a podcast.
(Robbie laughing)
It goes a lot of places, you know,
it is listening to meaningful podcasts like Rich's.
I can't really do audio books.
Sometimes it's music when I'm in a big challenge,
what I've found is I fixate on a couple of songs
or artists and it just gets on repeat.
This summer was Tyler Childers, "Nose On The Grindstone"
I think that song, just the name of the song,
"Nose On The Grindstone," like it was where I was at.
And then a lot of it is me just going through my life,
that kind of free association.
But you know, a lot of this,
I remember on the Colorado Trail, it was like,
that was the hardest part of the summer physically.
And I would have those like things where it's like, oh,
you're in all these enlightened moments
of why I was doing it.
It was so, yeah, whatever.
And then I'd be like,
oh, it's just cause you're a bad motherfucker, you know?
And like, just stick with that one for a minute.
So yeah, it goes all over the place.
I can't do music all the time.
It gets to where it just overwhelms you.
I'd say probably 30% of the time
and the rest is sifting through these free association
thoughts and just coming up with new things,
I wanna do dreaming about the future,
whether that be running or the other parts of life
that really matter.
It's not all about running.
I just have a question about community.
So somebody who worked in nightlife and restaurant industry,
I know the communities work hard party even harder.
And then you decided to take an athletic route
and start running races and stuff like that.
So I'm sure over the years, your community has changed
from partying to healthier living, running,
athleticism in general.
How was that transition?
Did you experience kind of like loneliness in between
where you kind of left the party scene,
but you haven't built yet more healthy, different community?
Was it lonely at times?
Well, initially it wasn't too bad
because I was still in the restaurants.
I wasn't going out afterwards.
So I still had that community around me.
Really, I think we're more of the isolation came,
was we moved eventually from Austin up to Denver, Colorado,
and it was just Shelly and I,
and friendships were hard to come by.
As you get older, it's harder.
So it was a lot of just running alone.
But then you over time gradually have started to make
friends within this world, meaningful friendships,
like Hellah, like William, Rich and in with those it, yeah,
but there was, I think the easy to that is,
there's definitely been some of that.
There's been some lonely times in isolation,
but one of the things I love about these big challenges
that brings people together, I can not do these by myself.
And I'm really lucky to have an amazing support group
around me.
And what I love is it gives us this like real,
like time together.
It's very like concentrated and it's beautiful and fun.
So I think it's instead of like always having people around
being at the bar partying,
it's like I have a lot of alone time,
but then when I do have people around it's meaningful
and it's just concentrated good time.
I think, just to piggyback on that piece
a little bit, the comfort with the alone time comes
with getting comfortable with who you are, right?
Like if you're uncomfortable with who you are
and you've been spending a lot of your time
with, you know, in recovery parlance,
it's called lower companions.
Like you're, you know, you're out partying
and then you wanna switch up your life.
You wanna be sober, or you wanna invest your time
and your energy and healthier pursuits.
It does require finding a new community of people
to surround yourself with who are vibrating
at a higher level and are kind of a little bit further down
the path of where you wanna go.
And along that journey is the inside work of, you know,
reckoning with whatever was leading you down the darker path
and clearing that out and getting comfortable
with who you are so that when you are alone,
you're not feeling less than,
but you're actually comfortable with who you are
because you'd like the person that you are becoming.
And the great news is for anybody who lives
in this amazing city,
there is every possible community of people doing any number
of things that are available to you as a person
who's, you know, trying out new things
and trying to figure out where you fit in.
You seem to have been touched deeply
by the Navajo Region.
I'm just wondering if you can tell us a little bit about,
about that area and why it moved you so greatly.
The people.
It's just, it's like, as I ran across the U.S.
like not a lot of people ask what you're doing
and if they do, and you're like,
I'm running across U.S. and they say,
"Oh, okay."
Back on their phone. And you're like,
"Did you not hear what I just said?"
And in the Navajo Nation,
almost every car stopped and they wanted to know
what I was doing.
And they were proud for me to be,
have chosen to come through their land.
And that was just, it was touching.
They look you in the eye, they want to have conversation
and they're proud of what they have
and what they have isn't a lot.
And that really makes you feel really grateful
for the things you do have,
and also remind you to be grateful for what you have
and understand that it's, again,
it's all mindset and they just have a culture that's set up
in a way that they stay true to themselves
and they they're prideful in who they are.
And that really resonated with me.
Yeah. Hi, I have a question, Robbie,
can you talk about how you recover in-between your running?
No, because I know you used like hardware
and software tools, like both of your endurance
and also your mental state and that.
Yeah. One thing I realized this summer
was I think I often on runs like start to acknowledge
and define things and then I can explore them further.
And I realized that the pursuit
I'm on is one of trying to understand
how to sustainably move through space and time.
That's like the real way to say it.
And it's really just like how to find sustainable motion.
And I thought a lot about like native American cultures
and how before horses were around, they had to move by foot
and how they must've been so valued in society.
And so looking back when I ran across the United States,
that was all about my food choices.
And I thought if I went plant based,
that was the key to success
and I would be able to run indefinitely.
And then when this summer came around,
I realized through the Transcon,
there was a piece that I had missed.
And that piece I had missed was recovery.
I had no recovery plan.
And due to that, I wasn't sleeping a lot.
There were days that were a lot harder
than they needed to be.
I was having to dig in ways that had I gotten good rest,
wouldn't be there.
So recovery became the focal point.
And with that, one of my sponsors, we did the summer,
it was a Ten Thousand and then NuCalm,
and NuCalm is a neuroscience technology
that through a three-part system,
it brings your brain into alpha and theta waves.
And lets you get really meaningful rest when you need it.
And a lot of this summer was exploring that as a recovery
tool, and if it would really help me along the way
and the truth of it was is it was one of the pillars
of my success and then fast forwarding.
I went and helped William Goodge in the UK.
He also utilizes NuCalm and he used it in between
his marathons.
So essentially we talked a lot about his run
and it was 30 days, 48 marathons.
But he said,
because he would take a nap in between and use this
for him it was 48 days.
Like he got enough restful sleep in between
to take on the next day.
So that was kind of the thesis of this summer, recovery.
And that was the tool that I used to do it.
What I learned from William
also was he's like really strong.
He's muscular and that's my next one.
I've got to get more full body like a full body workout
going, which is good.
'Cause Ten Thousand has all the gear for that.
And maybe you can follow that journey
as I kind of get biceps and stuff.
We'll see.
(all laughing)
So I just had a question for as often as you guys
obviously train and I would love to hear from both of you
guys on this, honestly, for,
as often as you train as competitive as you guys are for as
long as you've been going, how is your why like evolved.
'Cause I'm sure the reason of why you started running
at this high level through the years has changed.
And I'm just curious how you kept like the fire burning,
like how you kept the competitive edge.
Yeah. I mean, for me is when we talk
about the big stuff,
like starting with the Transcontinental run,
the why there was con was very clear.
It was to promote a plant based diet.
I had a reckoning where I wanted to do something
that could help like the environmental fight.
And I found that a plant-based diet is a thing
that we as individuals can do.
And I knew it was good for my performance.
And I wanted to prove that and boast about this diet
and that's still like a core part of me,
but I did that work, right.
Like probably more than most people I ran across the country
to talk about it.
So it's like there.
And so the why now what I realized on that run
was I was also able to inspire people in other ways.
It wasn't all about the plant-based diet.
And knowing that by my efforts could encourage someone else
to pick up better habits,
like giving somebody the gift of running.
There's no better gift anyone's ever given me.
And so that keeps me going.
Yeah, my evolution is, is somewhat similar.
I mean, early on when I was heavily invested in training
and racing and ultra races,
a lot of it was initially selfish.
I wanted to prove something to myself
about my own capabilities.
I felt like I had things I needed to say for myself
and to prove to myself about my athletic potential.
And then that evolved into leveraging
it as similar to Robbie,
like a platform to talk about plant-based nutrition
and also a kind of human potential
as we start to age because I was doing it in my 40s.
And that became a narrative that created
kind of the foundation of what I do today.
But you know, I turn 55 next week.
So I'm in a very different stage of life than Robbie.
And it's a less,
it's really not about competition for me anymore.
My life is very different.
I have a lot of responsibilities and I'm privileged
to be in a situation where I have this platform
where I have the opportunity to communicate with people
like Robbie and share those conversations.
And that is really kind of like my focus
and in addition to being my vocation, like my passion.
So the idea that I'm gonna go and train 25, 30, 35 hours
a week to go do some challenge as appealing as that is
for me to like leave my life and live in a cabin and train,
like that's just not my life anymore,
nor do I want it to be my life anymore.
Like I wake up every day and think,
what is the thing that I can do today that will move
the needle in the most significant way
for the most number of people.
And often that's having podcast conversations
or writing or putting out a book or, you know,
getting on a plane to go give a speech somewhere.
And I think athletic pursuits have their place in that.
But I see myself now more as an ambassador
and somebody who can be a catalyst
for another individual's version
of what I've already experienced.
Like I don't feel like, yeah,
I could go train a lot and try to do something crazy,
but I've already pretty much proved to myself everything
that I needed to know about what I can and maybe can't do
as an athlete.
And so my focus is really more outward facing
and service oriented in terms of like trying to activate
other individuals because maybe not everyone's gonna run
across the country or do any other things that I've done.
But I think everybody inside of themselves
has some version of that.
And maybe that's becoming a stand-up comedian or a concert
pianist, or, you know, it doesn't even have to be athletic,
but the idea of trying to get people in a head space
to more deeply connect with expressing their inner potential
is kind of what I'm all about.
And that expression can come through the form of nutrition
movements, you know, business, any number of, you know,
creativity, any number of factors,
but movement is really the primary kind of force
behind all of it.
And that kind of ties it back to this idea of FAR,
Free Association Run,
which is really like using our bodies to try to connect
with our innate creativity so that we can be the most
expressed and the most expressed in our human potential.
Hey guys, thanks both for being here
has been great to hear you just curious,
I've heard a lot about the first step in running
and I think I have that piece down,
but the other thing you've talked a lot about is this idea
of a plant-based diet.
And I'm just curious,
like my mind's going a million miles a minute here,
but what you would consider kind of the first step
in that journey and what that really looked like for you
and Rich if you have anything on that too, I'm just curious.
I heard it said really well recently
by Brendan Brazier.
One of the like old school, like plant-based athletes
and I really liked what he said
and that look at it as a thing of not what you're taking
away from your plate, but what you're adding
and just like starting to put healthier things
on your plate, small steps and eventually your plate
just full of greens and healthy stuff.
And also for me, it's an idea of getting there over time
is probably the best approach because if I sit up here
and preach absolutism and that everybody should switch
to a plant-based diet tomorrow, you'll go home.
You'll try a week later, you're gonna fail.
And then you're never gonna look at it again
'cause nobody wants to fail.
So the acknowledgement first and foremost
is that it will be better for you.
And it will definitely be better for this planet.
And then start making gradual steps in that direction.
I don't know how much more I can add to that.
When you asked the question,
I've made a little mental list of the things
I wanted to cover, and then he just set them all.
I think the other piece to that is holding it onto it
lightly, like make it a fun adventure.
It doesn't have to be like this martyrdom burdensome
thing where you're like, oh, it's gonna be really hard.
And I'm gonna have to think about this.
Like just have fun with it.
And some days you'll stray or whatever, and that's okay.
It's really trying to create a foundation of habits
that you can sustain long-term and treat it like,
you know, a journey as opposed to a rigid binary thing.
Like I'm plant-based and then the minute, like Robbie said,
like you go off the rails and you think, well,
this is too hard and you just abandon it altogether.
And I really do think it is about crowding out
the unhealthy foods and just focusing on being excited
about trying new things and building
more and more healthy foods onto your plate,
and then paying attention to how you feel.
I think making that emotional connection to it, like, well,
I actually do feel better today and like, noting that like,
well, what did I eat?
And paying attention to that I think really roots you
in sticking with it longterm,
and then also figuring out your why for it
and your why can be like, I feel fat or I feel lousy
and I just don't wanna feel this.
It doesn't have to be like, I'm gonna save the world
or I'm saving the animals or anything.
If that's your thing, that's great.
It can be a very simple thing,
but I think understanding why it is that you would wanna try
to engage in healthier eating habits,
I think is important in kind of figuring out
how to stay the path.
Hi, hope this question makes sense.
I think all about like how I spend my time
and how my friends spend their time.
And there's a lot of like waste in that like lots of TV.
We don't like that much
and friends we're never gonna really be that close with.
And I feel like in both of your more like focused,
goal based lifestyle,
you likely have found ways to kind of cut
to what's important in your leisure time
outside of your goals.
And I'm interested in whether that was like a deliberate
process where you thought about your days and what should
stay and what should go.
Or it just happened over time?
I think for me,
it was just over time by like just focusing more
on the things that I do care about.
It just is gonna take a lot of time.
Like the training to run ultras is very time consuming.
And so, yeah, it eventually just whittles out that stuff.
I mean, it was never a conscious thing for me.
Like I don't have any negative associations with the people
I used to hang out with.
They're just not really there anymore.
Like I don't dislike those folks.
I'm just like, these are the things I do love
and that time in between is only gonna be given
to the people that really I care for and care about me.
Robbie, you talked about how running helped you
discover how, what it is to like be a man, I guess,
outside it's easy, you tackle these physical feeds.
Could you talk about your findings in like a mental aspect,
like what it did for your mental health
and that part of being a man.
Yeah, I think through like running
and also through my journey into being plant-based
like compassion became a big part of that,
looking at like, what are these kind of toxic things
that society tells us or what to be a man
and kind of like really looking at that and being like,
does that really make sense?
And one of those being compassion,
like trying to be a compassionate person,
this summer, as I was submitting, all of the fourteeners
like required being very calculated and very intentional
and those things are I learned from that to try
to be more of that in life, like to, and again,
try to be more intentional, not spout off, not, you know,
just be, have more calmness to my being.
Those are kind of big ones for me right now.
But it's always an evolution and I'm not perfect.
And then one also being,
looking at my running and seeing how hard
I've strived and focused on that and realizing
that there's so many aspects in life
and we can't be great at everything, but I do value running.
So I'm gonna try to be great at that,
but what are the other ones that I could put more time
and energy into perfecting?
And like, that's just being a good partner
or building a foundation for a future with a family
and things like that.
So just, yeah.
Using what I've learned through running
and applying it to other aspects of my life.
Hey guys, I have a question for both of you.
So when you're like training for something specific,
there are days where you can like get caught up
in like a high and like you have a purpose
'cause it's like bigger than you.
So when you're like finish or the challenge,
how do you sort of deal with like the fallout?
'Cause like you don't really have that thing to lean on
anymore and so how do you,
like if you're having like a tougher time during day
how do you like have something to lean on?
For me, like that was a really big surprise
after finishing the Transcon.
I think I assumed when I got done,
like it was gonna change my life.
Like life was just gonna be easy, rainbows, birds,
chirping and all that good stuff.
And reality was it wasn't that, you know,
there was an immense amount of depression that came after.
And I think what I learned from that is just the knowledge
that it's coming.
And so just being able to face it and be ready for it
and learning practices of things that can keep me balanced,
going back to, I spoke of NuCalm this technology
I was using.
That's a big one.
The way it works, it essentially clicks you
into deep meditation.
I don't know how to meditate,
but this allows me to have a meditation practice.
And that's helped me a lot since the Colorado Crush
is just to find peace and serenity at some point in the day
that can carry me through until the next day.
And then maybe looking towards another goal.
It doesn't mean it needs to be the next week,
but just start thinking about what it is 'cause it's good
to always have something to look forward to,
but don't hide from things by doing that,
but get back in the game,
even if it just means training for the year
until that next thing comes around.
For me, that's about sort of disassociating
my identity from the results of my actions.
So how I do in a race or how many copies of a book
that I write, you know, how well does that do,
all that kind of stuff, like whatever goal it is that you
set for yourself, if you become too tightly wound up
about the result of that journey towards that goal.
I think that's what leads to peaks and valleys
in terms of your emotional state in the,
so I try to just focus on what is the next thing
in front of me to do?
So I'm not racing like Robbie or doing crazy ultra
challenges like I was, you know, 10 plus years ago,
but I'm putting out creative things and it's easy for me
to get very caught up in like how that is gonna be received
by the public and then calibrate how I feel about myself
based upon that.
And the less that I do that and the more I disassociate
and just focus on the work, the journey, the process,
the fact that I just love, like going out and running or,
you know, creating something that I can share with the world
and focus on that piece of it and let go of the results
aspect of it.
Then that seems to ameliorate those like valleys
that I would experience ordinarily emotionally.
Hi, up here.
I'm so sorry if you've touched on this already,
I came in a bit late, but it's a two-part question on sleep.
First of all, I want to know if you're doing anything
in the realms of sleep and sleep science like we're having,
we now have access to understanding
what thermal control does for sleep.
What a sunlight does versus a circadian rhythm.
Are you doing anything to optimize your sleep?
And also part two of the question is,
are you wearing any,
are you tracking any data using wearables,
such as whoop or a ring or you're looking at the data
you're optimizing from that data to sleep question.
You can talk for hours on this but go ahead.
I think we both have one side of this,
(Robbie laughing)
the sleep side.
Yeah. That again, that's kind of the thesis
of this summer's run was recovery.
And what is the basis of recovery?
We can talk about NormaTec boots.
We can talk about all this stuff,
but it really comes down to rest.
And I do, I use NuCalm it's this neuroscience technology
been around for 15 years.
It started off as a medical device slowly graduated its way
into where you can get it for 50 bucks a month.
And it brings your brain into alpha theta waves
and their restorative sleep happens
or like restoration happens.
And I found this summer that it was the key to my success.
The difference between me on the Transcon
and me this summer night and day, like on the Transcon,
somebody had to bring my coffee every morning.
They had to like scrape me off the bed and out the door.
And then this summer I was making my own coffee
and waking my crew up, telling them I was gonna leave.
And I think like that was a testament to this practice
that I've gotten through this tech.
And then also a little bit of it being that my body and mind
have adapted to these big efforts.
But it was something that I just miss so much
on the Transcon and had no thought about recovery.
I thought if I went hard, I would fall asleep at night
and it wouldn't be a problem.
But the reality is you're so keyed up sleep came.
It was just so hard.
And this summer being able to utilize that made it just
that much.
It was just, it was profoundly different.
So that works for me NuCalm.
I'm obsessed with sleep.
I am convinced that sleep is the greatest mover
in terms of performance enhancement.
You could, like Robbie said,
you could talk about all these modalities,
but ultimately the one thing that will help your body repair
itself the most effectively is like getting
an incredible night of sleep.
And we all know that experience of waking up
after one of those amazing elusive nights
where you just feel bulletproof and thinking
if I could eat a replicate this experience every day,
like my life would just expand in, you know, exponentially
I know that like, as you get older,
sleep becomes more and more elusive
and I've got more and more conscious about the practices
that I undertake to try to, you know,
take my best shot at ensuring the best night of sleep
Robbie's been like bugging me about NuCalm forever.
I mean, I can't tell you how many emails,
like you got to get on the NuCalm.
So I just got the kit, I haven't tried it yet,
but anyway, we'll, we'll shelve that for now,
but he's quite the evangelist of that.
But I have gone to some pretty extreme lengths
to get a good night of sleep.
I live in Southern California.
So I live in this climate,
but I've been sleeping outdoors in a tent
for like two and a half years at this point.
Like every night, like not occasionally,
like that is my bedroom.
Like I sleep outside, I have a weighted gravity blanket,
I've got the sleep mask, I do the periodized eating.
Like I try all of this kind of stuff to put myself
in the best position to, you know,
have the best night of sleep.
And I think it's super important and it's kind of nutty
the some of the stuff that I've done.
And maybe if I start doing NuCalm,
I can move back into the house.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
(all laughing)
Anyway whatever it is.
Like, I'll try it because like,
I just wanna feel great every day.
And I know what it feels like when you have a great night
of sleep as an athlete,
but also just in terms of how my brain works
and how I feel and how I interact with other people
when I'm well rested.
Like it's night and day.
Yeah. I have a question here.
I was just wondering,
talking about timing and especially like you like to sleep
and then you do an extreme amount of like workout.
I can imagine that there's a lot of people in the room
where have busy lifestyles in terms of careers
or having their own business.
Where do you find the time to do it?
And what's the transition of, you know,
in the restaurant scene,
how would you go from having a really successful career
to listening to like inspiring stories?
How would you ever get that?
'Cause it seems like you have to really step out of it
if you wanna go to the extreme levels,
unless you'd wanna keep it to just a hobby.
I think for me, it's just like,
what do you value?
You know, and like finding out what really does matter
to you and makes you feel your best
and having an honest conversation with yourself
about that and then pursuing it from there.
And as far as budgeting the time for it, I mean,
I want to feel my best and have the most quality
experience possible.
And if that's what it requires is eight hours of sleep
and that's what I'm gonna do.
And I like don't wanna beat a dead horse,
but like the NuCalm really helps me to do that.
And it minimizes it,
(all laughing)
it minimizes the time you got to put into that and like,
yeah,-
We're here for-
I know it just keeps talking about sleep
and it just keeps coming up.
To add to that a little bit.
I mean, I think there is this weird idea
where if you wanna do something that interests you,
that it has to be super extreme,
or you got to quit your job, or, you know,
kind of do this whole life overhaul.
And I don't think that's how it works.
It's not how it worked for me.
That's not how that happened for Robbie?
For me, it's just about paying attention to your curiosity.
Like, what gets you excited?
What is that thing that lights you up,
being aware of what that is, and then trying to, you know,
consciously give that energy within the construct
of your busy life and maybe that's 10 minutes a day
to indulge yourself by watching a video
about something you always wanted to learn
about or whatever it is.
It doesn't mean that you have to, you know,
throw your whole life out the window
and pursue some harebrained dream.
But I think it's about increasingly carving out more
and more time to devote energy to the things
that make you feel alive, because life is short, man.
And if you're not doing that,
then you're missing out on a lot of beauty in life.
So just, and then being open to where it leads you
is kind of how I've always done everything
without judging yourself against some idea
of what it should or should not look like.
Yeah, it's an evolution, right?
Like just start doing those things that matter
and more time comes for it if it's what you value.
Hi, excuse me.
Oh, you both talked about your why's for, or your purpose.
I'm curious if you have any words of wisdom
or ways that you've come to understand the journey
of our process of defining or gaining clarity,
clarity around your why.
Mine comes through the running,
through this Free Association.
I mean, it's just like,
that's where I go to evolve these ideas.
And again, it goes back to how I have to define something.
I have to find it in my mind as being a part of who I am.
And then once I find it, I can work on it
and I can once the identifying it happened,
then that can become a pillar of my why,
but first I have to discover it
and I discover it through running.
Repeat the question.
It's an elusive thing.
Go ahead.
And so in the absence of knowing your purpose,
if you had any words of wisdom or advice on,
or now that you are like, have clarity around your why,
a new understanding of the process of identifying
or finding clarity around your why?
Yeah. And your question starts with this idea
of like trying to identify what your purpose is, right?
Mm-mmh.
And that being a precursor to what your, why is,
I mean, I think it's easy to get caught up
in all this jargon, and I've said this before,
but I think a lot of these words,
like you live a life of passion
and, you know, find your purpose and all of that.
I think it makes it's very constrictive
and I think it makes people feel guilty
or ashamed if they don't know what their purpose is,
or they're not living this idealized life of passion.
And I don't really think about life in those terms
or in that context.
Like for me, it's just always been about
trying to pay attention to myself, trying to honor
and recognize when I have an impulse to do something
I'm trying to evaluate, whether that's something true
and that's in alignment with like a higher version of myself
and then giving myself permission to pursue that.
And that for me began with I'm gonna go running,
you know, it didn't have to mean some big thing
or be a purpose driven thing with a why behind it.
It really began with a whisper
and having the kind of self-respect to say,
I'm gonna honor that whisper because I'm worth it.
And you know, my higher self is trying to communicate
with me in some way, and I don't know what that means,
but I'm gonna follow that.
I'm gonna pull on that thread and I'm gonna see
where it leads me,
and all the other stuff gets figured out along the way.
So for me, it's about trying to just be in alignment
with that higher voice and the more that I can live
in that space.
And then a lot of these other questions kind of get answered
for me.
Thank you.
I don't know if mine does profound.
So my question is 56 miles alone
on the Colorado Trail versus thousands of people
in Central Park for most of the time you're running,
what are like the easier and harder parts
of both of those efforts?
Because even I've found like on the trail, you're alone,
that's a much different thing than someone's trying
to like push your pace 10 steps behind you
for like an hour and a half.
Well, Central Park loop challenge
came at a great time.
It was the first day of spring, the year coming out of COVID
bring on all the people you can,
like not seen people in quite a while.
So that was just really nice.
It was nice to have that, there's so much good people
watching to be done in the city.
And just like in the same way,
it's like trying to spot a wild animal in the mountains.
But both of them worked for me.
I think the duality of it's really nice
to have a little bit of both.
That day on the Colorado Trail,
luckily like I performed really well.
Like I felt good for the majority of it.
They're both just, you're out in the wild
either way you look at it, you know, like between the two.
So they're very starkly different,
but there's also a lot of similarities, I guess, yeah.
I heard you guys talking about
just what loosely sounded like reaching for the best version
of yourself.
The second self-actualization piece, if you will.
I would love to hear either of you guys we'll lay
that to potentially in the past being in recovery
and kind of like what that means to tie those two together
or kind of not seeing that best version of yourself
that striving towards the true voice of the bad,
and kind of seek out something new.
Yeah. I mean, that's a great question, you know,
in recovery parlance,
they say the road gets narrower, right.
Which means things that you used to do that you used to feel
okay about that you used to be able to get away with as you
kind of trod this path towards greater self-actualization
become less and less resonant with that higher self
and have to be discarded, right?
And it's kind of a bummer.
It's like, really, I gave up this and this and this,
and now I've got to give up this too, but you know,
in your heart of hearts that it's gotta go, right?
And so it's like this constant shedding practice
of letting go of old layers,
stepping into new version of yourself, experimenting,
figuring out what resonates with you
and trying to walk this path of deep integrity with self,
which is a process of self inquiry
that only you are in a position to evaluate for yourself.
So for me, yeah, I got sober in 1998.
I've been around the block with 12 step and recovery
and learned a few things along the way.
And I can tell you that journey is not linear.
It's up and down and all over the place.
And some days are better than others
because we're human beings and we're messy
and we're not built like robots to function
in a linear fashion.
And, you know, I've had for every step forward, two steps
back trying to figure out who I wanted to be in the world
and what that would look like and what that means.
And it's been a journey of bingo of, you know,
the lower companions and behaviors that didn't serve me,
that involved, not just substances, but all manner
of character defects that I battle with and, you know,
behaviors that I used to indulge without, you know,
thinking twice about that become more and more intolerable,
the closer that you kind of get to becoming, you know,
that version of yourself that you aspire to be,
but I can tell you, well, you know,
when I began the journey,
I thought my life is gonna be boring.
And I was gonna live this life of deprivation
and martyrdom, like I was sort of prison sentence
and my experience has been, you know, quite the contrary.
I mean, the idea that I'm sitting up here
doing this right now is like completely surreal to me
because I never lose touch with how I felt
and the person that I was back in 1998
when I was broken and alone, and really felt like
I had no future.
And that hopelessness is something that I need to revisit
in order to kind of connect with the gratitude
for what I get to do today.
But my point being that when you blaze this path
and you commit yourself to this ethos,
which is very much a part of Ten Thousand
better than yesterday, that your life will expand
in lockstep with the level of commitment that you apply
to that, and it puts you in a position for amazing things
to happen, you know, for that magic to happen,
for you to be in the right place at the right time,
for that thing that you always wanted to occur
to actually occur.
I think we're out of time.
I just wanna thank everybody for coming out today.
It's Saturday morning, you guys would be doing anything.
And the fact that you showed up, you went running,
you joined us for this conversation.
Just my heart is full.
I'm so grateful to be able to be here with all of you today.
Thank you to everybody at Ten Thousand
for not only supporting myself and Robbie,
but putting together this amazing event for us to indulge
in community on this level.
So I'm just happy to be here and appreciate all you guys.
So thank you.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)